Heute im Rasenfunk.
Alexander Schur, das ist ein Märchen, ein unglaubliches Märchen. Der Frankfurter schießt Eintracht Frankfurt in die Bundesliga.
Langhals fliegt vorbei und der Ball ist im Tor und Augsburg ist open. Schluss vorbei aus der SSV Ulm, das A- und P-Team steht für attraktiv und preiswert in der Bundesliga. Und jetzt ist das letzte Kapitel im verrücktesten Fußballmärchen der Saison geschrieben.
Also mich bringt nichts mehr so in Zweitligastimmung wie dieses Intro. Hallo liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, schön, dass ihr den Rasenfunk eingeschaltet habt. Das hier ist die Ligatur. Wir wollen heute sprechen über die 2. Bundesliga der Männer. Und wie immer habe ich drei fantastische Gäste. Ich freue mich sehr, einen alten Bekannten des Rasenfunks hier zu begrüßen. Kevin Bublitz ist da vom Padercast, also hallo Kevin. Ja, schön, dass du mal wieder da bist. Außerdem auch schon hier alt bekannt. Ich bekomme immer noch Rückmeldungen zu unserem Tribüngespräch von Anno Dazumal, Sebastian, als wir eigentlich die Frage gestellt haben, wie ist der FCK dahingekommen, wo er jetzt ist, also finanziell gesehen. Es ist aber immer gute Rückmeldungen. Hallo Sebastian Zobel vom SWR und dem Nur der FCK-Podcast. Hi Sebastian.
Hi, auch ich sage nochmal vielen Dank für die Einladung.
Geht das dir auch noch so, dass du immer noch Rückmeldungen zu diesem Tribüngespräch kriegst oder läuft das nur bei mir auf?
Das ging noch lange danach so tatsächlich, aber jetzt aber auch schon länger nicht mehr.
Ja, jetzt langsam hat sich es auch so ein bisschen beruhigt. Ich glaube, die Sensationsgeier sind jetzt weggeflogen vom FCK, beziehungsweise, wobei, wir reden ja gleich drüber. Und dann haben wir noch ein Neuling hier. Ich freue mich sehr, dass Thorsten Wiese hier ist, von einem relativ neuen Fortuna Düsseldorf-Podcast. Gebrabbelrotweiß heißt der. Hallo Thorsten, schön, dass du da bist.
Ja, hallo zusammen und danke für die Einladung.
Ja, aber das ist genau so soll es ja sein. Ich freue mich so, wenn es noch nicht Prominente gibt, die ohne Hilfe von Studio Bommensen Fußball Podcast starten. Das muss dann gefördert werden hier im Rasenfunk. Also Gebrabbelrotweiß, das empfehle ich jetzt einfach mal gleich. Das ist sehr schön, dass es noch so unabhängige Podcast-Ideen gibt. Wie seid ihr denn drauf gekommen?
Ja, also tatsächlich waren wir der Meinung, dass Fortuna Düsseldorf, was das Thema Podcasting betrifft, einfach noch nicht sehr breit aufgestellt ist. Und dass ein Podcast mehr dem ganzen Vereinsumfeld nicht unbedingt schaden würde. Und ja, so haben wir die Idee. Tatsächlich in der Hinrunde war es beim Auswärtsspiel in Nürnberg ein sehr bitterer Tag. Vielleicht die schlechteste Leistung in der letzten Rückrunde. Da haben wir gesagt, jetzt müssen wir wohl einschreiten.
Das heißt, es ließ sich auch so ein bisschen ein Kreis, oder wie man heutzutage sagt, ein Full Circle-Moment. Weil wir sprechen ja nach einem Auswärtsspiel beim 1. FC Nürnberg, jetzt über die Fortuna hier im Rasenfunk.
Wie schön. Das habe ich zu meinem Podcast-Kollegen Andi auch gesagt. Jetzt sind wir wieder in Nürnberg und schauen, wie die Dinge jetzt aussehen.
Schauen, wie die Dinge jetzt aussehen. Nämlich ganz fantastisch 5 zu 0 beim Club gewonnen. Aber da wollen wir gleich darüber sprechen. Wir blicken gleich allgemein auf den Spieltag zurück und dann auf eure Vereine im generellen, aber vorher noch der Hinweis. Alles, was der Rasenfunk macht, ist Paywall-Werbe- und Sponsoren-frei. Wir finanzieren uns ausschließlich über eure freiwillige Unterstützung auf rasenfunk.de/supportersclub. Erfahrt ihr, wie man uns unterstützen kann? Und unter kiosk.rasenfunk.de könnt ihr uns den Shop leer räumen und dafür eure Geschenke für Weihnachten alle in einem Rutsch abfrühstücken. Was sagt mir, ich liebe dich, Mama, als eine Rasenfunkt-Tasse? Ich wüsste es nicht. Also, schön, dass ihr alle da seid. Lasst mal ganz kurz noch so grob auf den letzten Spieltag blicken. Sebastian, was vom letzten Spieltag ist dir noch besonders in Erinnerung geblieben?
Ich muss zugeben, ich habe bedingt durch die Situation in Lautern nicht allzu viel mitbekommen vom vergangenen Spieltag, aber ich habe natürlich das gesehen und darüber gestaunt, worüber, glaube ich, ganz Fußball Deutschland gestaunt hat, was Heuer Fernandez da im Herbie HSV Pauli gemacht hat. War echt eine krasse Mischung aus, oh Gott, tut mir der Mann leid, dass ihm so was passiert. Und halt so dieses Sensationsding, so man guckt hin und lacht. Aber ich glaube, das ist echt die erste Sau in dem Moment. Also so ein kurioses Eigentor habe ich echt schon sehr lange nicht mehr gesehen. Und dann ausgerechnet noch im Derby, das ist natürlich, das ist krass. Ich habe lange Zeit in Hamburg gelebt und da auch studiert und weiß, wie viel Feuer da drin ist und dass dir das dann in so einem Ding passiert, ist natürlich echt extrem bitter. Aber ich muss auch sagen, Heuer Fernandez ist für mich immer schon so ein bisschen im Fokus, weil ich, also sein Spiel hat ja auch eine recht offensive Spielweise bzw. er ist ja oft auch während des Spiels sehr weit aus seinem Kasten raus und bei ihm hat es mich eigentlich schon ganz oft gewundert, dass er nicht sowieso schon mehr kuriose Tore bekommt, was natürlich keine Eigentore wären, aber ich habe mich echt bei ihm auch schon oft gefragt, warum er nicht schon öfter überlüpft worden ist, weil er da doch sehr viel ins Risiko geht. Aber das ist mir auf jeden Fall hängen geblieben und ich sage mal so, da ich natürlich auch mit einem Auge schon auf den Pokalgegner Nürnberg geschielt habe, habe ich natürlich auch wahrgenommen, dass die Fortuna da einen recht überzeugenden Auswärtssieg gefeiert hat. Aber da werden wir gleich noch ein bisschen mehr dazu hören.
Das glaube ich allerdings auch. Aber jetzt hätte ich gerne eine kurze Abstimmung, ein paar Handzeichen und ich werde es für die Podcast-Hörenden dann übersetzen. Wer von euch, also wir alle haben dieses Eigentor von Heuer von Landes nämlich angesehen und wir alle werden es auch mehrfach gesehen haben, weil es war so was, was man zum ersten Mal gesehen hat, dass man sich gedacht hat, Moment, was? Und dann hat man es nochmal gesehen. Ist einem von euch aufgefallen, dass da beide St. Pauli-Spieler schon auf der Strafraumlinie standen, als der Abschluss ausgespielt wurde? Hand hoch, wer es gesehen hat?
Nicht gesehen, aber ich habe es heute tatsächlich schon in einem anderen Format vernommen, dass das wohl der Fall gewesen ist.
Ja, ja, also sollen beide Treffer irregulär gewesen sein. Zum ersten kann ich nicht sagen, ich habe es nicht verfolgen können, hatte hier mit Schneefall und Kindern zu tun. Aber ich habe natürlich Wiederholungen von diesem Eigentor von Heuer Fernandez gesehen. Mir ist es nicht aufgefallen, beide Treffer sind irregulär. Felix Zweier war der Schiedsrichter.
Und der Platzwart, den wollen wir nicht vergessen. Der hat auch ein bisschen Anteil, denn da war ja ein Hügel, bzw. der Ball ist auf jeden Fall sehr unglücklich aufgesprungen, bevor Heuer Fernandez ihn eingeschweistert hat.
Ja gut, aber das ist ja Gott sei Dank dann für mehrere Tage nicht mehr vorgekommen im Kontext mit St. Pauli, bis sie dann in Homburg gespielt haben im DFB-Pokal. Also nicht exakter selber, aber etwas sehr Ähnliches.
Aber man muss vielleicht schon nochmal darüber reden, wie die überhaupt in diese Situation kommt. Das ist einfach auch schlecht gelöst, glaube ich, in dem Fall. Also ich glaube, es darf ihm natürlich nicht passieren, oder es sollte ihm nicht passieren, aber ich glaube, man kann das spielerisch auch anders lösen, dass er gar nicht in die Situation kommt, dass er da so nah vor seinem Tor das Ding wegbolzen muss.
Ja, ich meine, das Ironische war, wenn das nicht so bolzt, dann geht er auch nicht so rein. Eigentlich haben sie ja tatsächlich eine Überzahl dann quasi ballfern gebildet. Also irgendwie hat es schon Sinn ergeben, weil beide St. Paulianer dann quasi angelaufen sind und mit einem Querpass hättest du den auf den anderen Flügel verlagern können. Aber Mai geht halt dann schief, dann lachen halt alle. Hat irgendjemand von euch noch zufällig dann rausgefunden, wie dann der HSV auf 2 zu 2 zurückkommen konnte? Weil ich habe nur das Ergebnis gesehen, dachte mir so, naja, dann war es jetzt auch alles nicht so schlimm. Ihr wart alle mit euren Verein beschäftigt, ich sehe schon. Ich sehe einen leeren Blick bei Kevin.
Ich hatte einen Kumpel, der ist HSV-Fan, und hat gesagt, guckst dir bitte nicht an, das ist das Tor des Jahres gewesen oder das Kacktor des Jahres gewesen. Und wie wir noch einen Ausgleich geschafft haben, keine Ahnung, ist halt dörbig. So hat er es mir begründet und dann habe ich mir das auch nicht mehr angeguckt.
Du bist halt ein guter Freund, du hältst dich daran, was die Leute sagen. Gibt es noch was, Kevin, vom letzten Spieltag, was du noch bemerkenswert fandest?
Ich bemerkenswert fand, dass Hannover 96 einen Angstgegner hat, der Esti Paderborn heißt. Es gibt nicht viele Vereine, die den Esti Paderborn als Angstgegner haben. Einen vielleicht noch, den wir hier auch vertreten haben, aber die haben auch schon mal gegen uns gewonnen. Aber Hannover 96 hat noch nie gegen uns gewonnen.
Na jetzt wünschte ich fast, ich wäre etwas länger draußen gewesen, wenn die Sprache gleich darauf kommt.
Ja, darüber sprechen wir noch. Vielleicht kann man noch der Vollständigkeit halber erwähnen. Kiel nach einem 3 zu 2 gegen Wiesbaden, jetzt Tabellen 2, also St. Pauli auf 1, Kiel auf 2, HSV auf 3, eine norddeutsche Tabelle. Dann kommt schon die Fortuna, über die werden wir gleich sprechen. Und ich denke, das 5 zu 1 von Hertha gegen Elbersberg ist auch noch mal erwähnenswert. Ich suche bei Elbersberg jetzt schon seit längerem nach einem Gast hier für dieses Format. Ich hatte auch schon zwei Leute gefunden, die hatten beide keine Zeit leider. Und als ich dann das Ergebnis gesehen habe am Wochenende, dachte ich mir, ach, naja, vielleicht war das gar nicht so schlimm, dass das jetzt nicht der richtige Zeitpunkt war, um darüber zu sprechen, warum Elbersberg so stark ist.
Du hast sie eingeladen, nachdem wir da gespielt hatten, ne?
Ja, also halt jetzt vor diesem Spieltag. Habt ihr vor zwei Wochen gespielt?
Ja, also genau, dann haben wir 4-1 da verloren.
Ja, oh Gott, ja, da habe ich mich wieder geärgert, weil ich völlig falsch gequatscht habe.
Nachdem Schalke gegen die verloren hat, haben wir da verloren.
Ja, Schalke, gutes Stichwort. Schalke kann noch gewinnen 4 zu 0 gegen Osnabrück. Damit auf den Relegationsplatz zementiert. Schalke 0-4, herzlichen Glückwunsch dazu. Also, das war so im Groben der letzte Spieltag. Wenn ihr es genauer wissen wollt, dann müsst ihr sowieso andere Podcasts hören. Das ist ja eh klar, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Aber dann lasst uns mal auf eure Vereine blicken und wir gehen nach Reihenfolge der Tabelle. Und damit habe ich schon verraten, wir dürfen jetzt schon über die Fortuna sprechen. Die liegt nämlich mit 27 Punkten auf Prang 4. Nur einen Punkt hinter dem HSV, zwei Punkte hinter Kiel und vier Punkte hinter St. Pauli. Punkt gleich mit Fürth. Man hat 34 Tore schon erzielt. Da gibt es kein Team in dieser Liga, das mehr Tore erzielt hat. 18 hat man kassiert. Und fünf von den Erzielten, die kommen ja jetzt alleine von diesem Wochenende. Vielleicht, Thorsten, fangen wir da mal an. Was war denn da los in Nürnberg?
Ja, es ist ja immer so eine zweigeteilte Sache. Einerseits spielt deine eigene Mannschaft ziemlich überzeugend und zumindest ab dem Schiedsrichterwechsel. Das hat man ja auch selten. Ab dem Schiedsrichterwechsel, ich glaube 26. oder 28. Minute, spielt deine Mannschaft sehr überzeugend ab diesem Punkt. Und auf der anderen Seite hast du einen Gegner, der so dermaßen von der Rolle ist, ab im Prinzip dem ersten Gegentor, dass er sich überhaupt nicht mehr wehrt. Also das hat definitiv mit reingespielt. Nürnberg hat enorm körperlos gespielt. Die Fortuna haben im Prinzip niemals gestört bei ihren Angriffen. Und das, muss man ja sagen, haben wir diese Saison schon öfters gezeigt. Wenn man uns bei der Arbeit nicht stört, dann machen wir es ja auch richtig. Und entsprechend viele Tore kann es dann schon mal setzen. Es war schon der zweite Auswärtssieg mit 5 zu 0 diese Saison. Der andere war, ja, wir haben sie leider nicht heute hier in Elbersberg. Ich glaube, Elbersberg, das einzige schlechteste Spiel dieser Saison, haben sie gegen uns gemacht. Aber zurück zum Spiel in Nürnberg, wir waren im Prinzip 90 Minuten dominant. Nürnberg, eine echte Torschance zuzuschreiben, wäre wirklich übertrieben in diesem Spiel. Und bei der Fortuna läuft es halt spielerisch diese Saison enorm stark. Das ist sicherlich noch mal eine Verbesserung im Vergleich zur letzten Saison. Da haben sicherlich auch ein paar Transfers zu beigetragen. Diesen Sommer, wo man eben sagen muss, die ohnehin schon gute spielerische Qualität ist einfach noch mal da besser geworden. Und ja, in dem Spiel hat sich dann auch unser neuer Torjäger endlich gezeigt. Beziehungsweise es war ja schon die Woche vorher gegen Schalke so, wo wir ja auch fünf Treffer erzielt haben oder hatten. Vincent Fermet, der jetzt mit sieben Treffern zu Christos Cholis aufgeschlossen ist, sich dann doch als Torjäger entpuppt, was viele Leute, inklusive mir, in der ersten Hälfte der Hinrunde so noch nicht gedacht hatten. Da waren wir schon etwas besorgt, dass die Ausfälle im Sommer, namentlich vor allem Kofnatsky und Ruben Hennings, sehr schwer wiegen würden und wir doch das ein oder andere Problem mit dem Tore schießen bekommen könnten. Nun, ist scheinbar doch nicht der Fall.
Meine Güte, diese tiefe Zufriedenheit, die aus jeder deiner Selben spricht, natürlich auch noch genährt von einem 2 zu 1 dann unter der Woche in Magdeburg, wo man das Spiel noch gedreht hat und damit ins Viertelfinale des DFB Pokals eingezogen ist. Also es läuft aktuell bei der Fortuna. Jetzt hast du aber schon mit Fermé einen der Neuzugänge angesprochen und vor allem auch schon zwei der namhaften Abgänge genannt. Rufen Hennings zu Sandhausen, Kovnatsky zu Bremen, Christoph Klarer ist noch zu Darmstadt gewechselt und Leone Fernandes Neto zu Salzburg. Was ist denn im Sommer bei der Fortuna passiert und wie konnte man das jetzt auffangen? Einen Namen hast du ja jetzt gerade schon genannt.
Genau, also es gab zwei relativ frühe Transfers. Beide kamen von Freiburg 2. Beide Spieler, der erste war eben Vincent Vermeil und der zweite Yannick Engelhardt, der auch eine relevante Rolle bei uns spielt, war Notenbester, Spieler zumindest nach Kickernoten letzte Saison, Feldspieler in der dritten Liga fürs Defensive Mittelfeld, der einzige Spieler, für den wir auch Ablöse diesen Sommer bezahlt haben, rund 600.000. Man mumkelt, der SC Freiburg hätte eine geheime Rückkaufoption, wie das so ist. Und 22 Jahre jung, also ein super junger Defensive Mittelfeld, der den fast durchgängigen Ausfall von Marcel Sobotka, unserem Vizekapitän, auch ein bisschen in dieser Hinrunde vergessen lässt. Ja, und Vincent Vermeid, der dann eben inzwischen für das Torschießen zuständig ist. Das waren so die ersten beiden Neuzugänge, die auch relativ früh eingetütet wurden. Klar, Rundspieler aus der unteren Liga, da ist es immer ein bisschen einfacher. Dann rumorten wieder die Leute in Düsseldorf, wie das häufiger der Fall ist. Und es kamen dann aber dann doch noch weitere Spieler. Und man muss sagen, wenn man sich die Liste der Zugänge diesen Sommer anguckt, dann muss man sagen, dass jeder im Prinzip schon eine mehr oder weniger wichtige Rolle in dieser Hinrunde gespielt hat. Jamil Zibat war ausgeliehen an Viktoria Köln, auch noch in der dritten Liga. Ist ein Eigengewächs, aber hier aus Düsseldorf, aus dem eigenen Nachwuchs. Sogar ein echter Düsseldorfer, das hat man heutzutage im Profifußball auch nicht mehr so unbedingt in seiner Elf stehen. Der jetzt, auch weil Andre Hoffmann seit dem Spiel in Rostock, ich weiß jetzt nicht, sechster oder siebter Spieltag ausfällt, in der Innenverteidigung einen super Job macht und mittlerweile sogar deutscher U21-Nationalspieler geworden ist. Und dann kamen eben so die Laien, auf die man in den letzten Jahren immer mal wieder gesetzt hat, die dann immer kurz vor Schluss kamen. Letzte Saison war es Michael Karbovnik, der ja auch noch zu den Abgängen diesen Sommer sozusagen zählt. Und jetzt waren es eben Christos Cholis von Norwich aus England geholt, eines der großen griechischen Top-Talente, sagt man, der letzten Jahre. Norwich hat immerhin mal 12 Millionen vor zwei Jahren für ihn bezahlt, der sich dann aber dort nicht so durchsetzen konnte. Und mein persönlicher Lieblingsspieler, wenn ich das so sagen darf, Isaac Bergmann-Johanneson, ein 20-jähriger Isländer, auch Nationalspieler schon, vom FC Kopenhagen in Schweden groß geworden fürs Mittelfeld, welches ja ohnehin schon ein Spielstück war mit Akteuren wie Appelkamp und Tanaka, eben Sobotka, der zusätzlich noch eine weitere spielerische Komponente bei uns reinbringt, sodass man eben sagen muss, dass diese Mischung aus spielerisch starken Spielern nahezu durchgehend durch die Bank, die aber im entscheidenden Moment auch mal, ich sag mal, die Zweikampfhärte durchaus zeigen, also Engelhard ist dazu zu nennen, Sobotka, wenn er denn fit ist, die Mischung scheint im Moment sehr gut zu stimmen. Plus die erfahrenen Leute, also wir haben in diesem Sommer, wenn man sich das Alter der Leute anguckt, doch relativ junge Spieler größtenteils geholt, aber die erfahrenen Leute wie Zimmermann, wie eben Sobotka oder Hoffmann, auch wenn sie jetzt teilweise ausfallen, die sind eben auch noch da und diese Mischung passt halt aktuell ziemlich gut, plus natürlich ein Trainer, den ich jetzt wahrscheinlich hier im 2. Liga-Podcast jetzt auch nicht mehr groß beschreiben muss, aber Daniel Tune ist natürlich ein Glücksgriff für Fortuna gewesen, jetzt fast zwei Jahre da, hat nie mehr als zwei Spiele am Stück verloren, hochsympathischer Typ und ja, der bringt das Ganze, also er hat selber neulich gesagt, er hat jetzt so langsam auch eine Mannschaft für seinen Fußball zusammen und ich glaube, das sieht man, dass die Rettchen immer besser greifen.
Und was ist das für ein Fußball, den die Fortuna spielt? Also weil du jetzt ja auch schon die spielerischen Fähigkeiten mehrfach so betont hast, suggeriert das für mich, dass es da eine weite Entwicklung gab zur letzten Saison?
Ja und nein ein bisschen. Ich kann mich sogar erinnern, dass ihr in der Liga-Tour letztes Jahr mal die Diskussion darüber hattet, wofür steht eigentlich der Fußball der Fortuna und da gab es glaube ich nicht so eine richtige Antwort darauf. Und da habe ich mir damals schon gedacht, ja das ist nämlich genau der entscheidende Punkt des Fortuna-Fußballs. Wir haben alles so ein bisschen im Repertoire. Ich meine, wenn man sich Statistiken anguckt, da wirst du dich sehr darüber freuen, Max, dann liegen wir vor allem natürlich bei den Flanken sehr weit vorne. Ich glaube Platz 2. Man sieht, ich bin ein bisschen vorbereitet, aber ich würde unser Spiel jetzt definitiv nicht auf ein reines flankenlastiges Spiel herunterbrechen. Wobei ich natürlich anmerken möchte, wenn man einen Mittelstürmer mit einer Körpergröße von 1,96 hat, der auch wirklich gut im Luftzweikampf ist, auch da glaube ich die fünf meisten Kopfballduelle der Liga gewonnen, dann ist das vielleicht auch durchaus ein probates Mittel mit Flanken zu agieren. Dazu kommt aber eben auch der Weg über das Mittelfeld. Also die Fortuna baut schon allein über Kastenmaier, der eher auch ein spielerischer Torwart ist, selten mit dem langen Hafer auf. Also da wird der Ball selten nach vorne gepühlt. Wobei man das jetzt durch den großen Stürmer Vermeij so ein bisschen mit ins Repertoire bekommen hat. Das heißt, in großer Not kann man den Ball eben auch gerade in die Mitte spielen und die Chance ist gar nicht so klein, dass Vermeij den irgendwie holt und weiterleiten wird. Aber prinzipiell versucht man eben durch Kombinationsspiel auch im zentralen Mittelfeld und da hat man eben mit Johanneson, mit Appelkamp, mit Tanaka, diese spielerisch starken Akteure, versucht man eben in diese Räume zu kommen, um dann eben am Strafraum gefährlich zu werden. Das klappt, würde ich jetzt sagen, bisher offensiv ja auch recht gut und auch defensiv, obwohl wir ja in diesen Spektakel spielen und vielleicht reden wir ja auch über dieses eine mit einem anderen Gast heute ja noch so ein bisschen.
Ich will über beide Spiele reden, die können sich beide schonmal warm machen.
Also in denen wir absurd viele Gegentore kassiert haben, haben wir im gesamten tabellarischen Vergleich ja auch glaube ich erst die drittmeisten Gegentore bekommen. Also das heißt auch die Defensive kann ihren Job durchaus vollführen und das und ich will jetzt langsam sein auch mit den Lobeshymnen aufhören, aber das eben mit einem der kleinsten Kader der Liga und auch durchaus nicht wenigen Verletzungen. Ich habe eben ja auch schon gerade zwei erfahrene Spieler angesprochen, jetzt die letzten Wochen und auch für den Rest des Jahres fehlt mit Matthias Zimmermann auch noch ein weiterer erfahrener Mann zusätzlich. Das ist durchaus bemerkenswert und ich denke, die Erwartungshaltung in Düsseldorf war nie, dass man von vornherein auf Platz 1 stehen müsste, aber dass man natürlich diesen Kontakt nach oben irgendwie hält und das gelingt aktuell und das gelingt sogar mit relativ spektakulären Spielen. Also siehe selbst, wie du sagtest, im Pokal in Magdeburg. Langweilig wird es bei uns gerade nicht.
Übrigens ganz liebe Grüße von Dirk Schuster an der Stelle. Ich glaube nämlich, man könnte fast behaupten, dass die Fortuna einen gewissen Anteil daran hat, dass der mittlerweile kein Trainer mehr in Kaiserslautern ist.
Echt, war dieses 3 zu 4 in Düsseldorf so schlimm für Lautern?
Das ist in Düsseldorf auf jeden Fall auch, sagen wir mal, so ein Thema. Wir haben Lautern kaputt gemacht. Aber ja, danach ja auch noch das Spiel gegen den HSV. Nach 3 ins Führung habt ihr auch noch 3-3 gespielt, meine ich. Also und die Verletzung natürlich von Ragnar Ache in dem Spiel war sicherlich auch bei euch einer der Gründe.
Also das ist, finde ich schön, dass das in Düsseldorf auch so quasi gesehen wird, dass die Fortuna Lautern kaputt gemacht hat. Aber seit dem Spiel war natürlich ein deutlicher Bruch drin. Der Top-Score-Top-Torjäger war danach weg. Jetzt ist er am Wochenende zum ersten Mal wieder aufgelaufen und direkt läuft es wieder. Also man könnte wirklich, also ich würde an der Stelle ganz gerne mal so eine Simulation durchspielen und würde die beiden Faktoren, also würde diesen Faktor Düsseldorf-Spiel beim FCK mal ein bisschen anders damit in die Simulation einbringen und gucken, wie ich dann aussehen würde. Dass du das nicht machen würdest, ist mir klar. Wir reden jetzt nur von der Simulation, aber das war echt in so einer Phase, wo man eigentlich, also ich glaube, hätte der FCK das Spiel gewonnen und Ragnar Acher hätte sich nicht verletzt, glaube ich, stünde der FCK jetzt in den Tabellen gefilmt, wo die Fortuna jetzt steht.
Und war das nicht damals, Thorsten, auch das erste Spiel mit den kostenlosen Eintrittskarten, das erste dieser Spiele, hat es da eine Rolle gespielt, deiner Meinung nach?
Ja, das erste Fortuna für alle Spiele war das und ich denke, was natürlich eine Rolle gespielt hat, war das ausverkaufte Stadion und ja, auch sicherlich eine sehr aufgeregte Atmosphäre. Prinzipiell hat sich aber in dem Spiel etwas gezeigt, was generell ein Merkmal der Fortuna in dieser Saison ist und zwar, dass sie sich von Rückschlägen innerhalb eines Spiels häufig nicht beeinflussen lässt. Es gab jetzt die Ausnahme im Schalke-Spiel, wo wir wirklich innerhalb von fünf Minuten zwei Gegentore kriegen, aber da möchte ich auch das Team sehen, was so was war, ohne mit der Wimper zu zocken, eben wegsteckt. Aber auch in dem Spiel war es so, obwohl wir 0-3 hinten lagen und Sebastian mag es mich gerne korrigieren, auch ein bisschen absurd 0-3 hinten lagen, wie die Tore da teilweise gefallen sind, hat die Mannschaft einfach weiter gespielt. Und das ist ein Merkmal, das hat es auch gegen Karlsruhe in dieser Saison gegeben. Zum Beispiel selbst in Magdeburg, als man lange Zeit jetzt im Pokal Probleme hatte, hat man sich am Ende doch irgendwie immer auf seine Stärken berufen. Das klappt nicht in jedem Spiel. Und diese Unkonzentriertheiten in der Abwehr sind sicherlich ein Faktor, wenn man über Schwächen und Dinge, die nicht so gut laufen, reden möchte, dann ist das sicherlich der Fall. Aber in der Partie natürlich angetrieben durch das volle Stadion. Und ich glaube auch, so ein bisschen ging es da auch um die Ehre. So jetzt haben wir hier dieses große Fortuna für alle Dinge, was durch die internationale Presse ja wirklich gegangen ist, was glaube ich alle in Düsseldorf ein bisschen überrascht hat. Also da möchte ich den finden, der das vorher so vorhergesagt hat, dass man sich da einfach so nicht verabschieden wollte. Und ja, jetzt ist es irgendwie eine legendäre Partie, zumindest auf unserer Seite geworden.
Aus 0-3, 4-3, später noch 5-3 gegen Schalke. Aber da gibt es natürlich einige wenige Teams, die in Düsseldorf gewinnen konnten. Und dazu gehören die Teufelskicker vom SC Paderborn. Und da muss ich jetzt natürlich schon die Frage an Kevin stellen. Ja, wie ist denn das überhaupt möglich? Ich höre hier nur positive Dinge über die Fortuna. Wie konnte denn das am dritten Spieltag klappen, dieses 2 zu 1?
Ja, wie das halt immer klappt gegen Düsseldorf. Nein, aber sehr oft. Also wir haben traditionell eigentlich immer ein gutes, man müsste jetzt sagen Händchen, ist ja falsch, also Füßchen, gegen die Fortuna. Ich weiß nicht, wo das herkommt, aber es ist in Paderborn tatsächlich auch immer eine große Vorfreude, wenn Zettel auf dem Spielplan als nächstes Fortuna Düsseldorf steht. Denn da steht sehr oft für erfolgreich gestaltete Spiele mit drei Punkten auf dem Konto, egal ob zu Hause oder auswärts.
Das ist bei uns aus irgendeinem Grund genau umgekehrt.
Ja, ich weiß. Also es ist tatsächlich, keine Ahnung. Max, du kennst ja auch Stefan, den Gründer von Paderkast, also von früher, der inzwischen dort hinten wohnt in der Ecke. Und das war für ihn immer ein großes Fest dann zu den Auswärts- und Heimspielen, also in einem Jahr quasi für ihn hinzugehen, denn er wusste immer, geht er abends glücklich nach Hause.
Vielleicht liegt es daran, weil er da in der Nähe wohnt.
Also in der Partie habe ich in Erinnerung, dass ihr, was für mich, es war ja dritter Spieltag, meine ich, gegen Paderborn, was für mich zu dem Zeitpunkt auf jeden Fall überraschend war, dass Kwasniok eine sehr defensive Taktik gewählt hatte und ihr enorm auf Umschaltspiel gesetzt hattet, was man aus der Vorsaison so von Paderborn eher nicht kannte. Also da hatte ich euch ganz anders erwartet und da habt ihr uns wirklich zweimal, also wirklich sauber ausgekontert und wir haben das halt wahnsinnig naiv vor allem, das weiß ich noch, das zweite Tor ist eines der naiv verteidigsten Tore diese Saison. Ich glaube, Conte war es dann der, der allerdings allen davon läuft.
Ja, der allen davon läuft, aber irgendwie nie trifft, außer halt dann gegen Düsseldorf.
Da konnte Conte mal nichts mehr machen.
Hat er das gemacht. Wenn er das öfter machen würde, würde der auch nicht mehr in Paderborn spielen, schon längst nicht mehr, weil ansonsten wäre das eine unfassbare Macht. Ähnlicher Typ dann wie Ragnar Ache, nur dass der halt das Tor trifft. Ist natürlich ein anderer Spielertyp, aber von der Qualität her wäre das dann ein ähnlicher Typ. Ja, also das ist tatsächlich so. Und wie du gesagt hast, da werden wir gleich wahrscheinlich noch drauf kommen. Mit dem defensiv ausgerichteten Spiel bei euch hat das viele überrascht in dieser Saison, gerade zu Beginn am dritten Spieltag. Denn eigentlich kennt man das seit Steffen Baumgart's Amtsantritt in Paderborn so nicht mehr.
Ja, das ist allerdings wahr. Da hat sich beim SCP-Mist was getan. Aber vorher müssen wir noch ganz kurz die Fortuna abschließen, auch wenn wir jetzt nur an der Oberfläche kratzen konnten. Man müsste noch viel tiefer rein gehen. Aber ich habe gehört, dafür soll es ja Fortuna Düsseldorf-Podcasts geben. Inzwischen sind mir zwei davon bekannt. Nächstes Wochenende Heimspiel gegen Kiel. Da könnte man in die Top 3 springen und dann noch mal ein Auswärts-Rematch bei Magdeburg. Ich glaube, die haben noch eine offene Rechnung jetzt mit der Fortuna. Du bist natürlich jetzt gerade sehr positiv gestimmt. Was glaubst du denn, muss im Vergleich zu den bisherigen Saisons in dieser Saison gut gehen, dass es vielleicht dann doch mal klappt mit dem Platz unter den ersten dreien?
Ja, ich hatte es eben schon mal kurz erwähnt. Wir haben einen der kleinsten Kader der Liga und sind nicht gerade verschont von Verletzungen. Da müssen wir sicherlich auf der einen Seite ein bisschen die Daumen drücken. Über die Winterpause werden im Prinzip, stand jetzt, alle Spieler zurückkommen für die Rückrunde. Das ist also durchaus positiv und wir müssen natürlich hoffen, dass es vielleicht in der Rückrunde dann auch, was das betrifft, ein bisschen besser läuft. Auf der einen Seite, auf der anderen Seite natürlich auch jetzt die Option und durch den Einzug ins Pokalviertelfinale, wie ja die anderen beiden Kollegen auch. Das haben wir noch gar nicht herausgearbeitet, glaube ich, dass hier drei DFB-Pokalfiertelfinalisten heute zu Gast sind.
Das wusste ich natürlich, als ich diese Runde zusammengestellt habe.
Das eröffnet natürlich auch nochmal die Möglichkeit, im Winter am Kader ein bisschen was zu tun. Ich hatte es auch schon erwähnt, lange Zeit hat man sich gefragt, ob der Sturm nicht zu dünn besetzt ist und quantitativ stimmt das auch immer noch. Man hat im Sommer, das habt ihr vielleicht mitbekommen, versucht, Simon Zoller zu verpflichten am letzten Spieltag, nicht am letzten Spieltag, am letzten Transfertag oder wie heißt es jetzt immer? Oh ja, Deadline Day, mein Lieblingsbegriff. Genau, den wollte ich aber unbedingt hier einschmeißen. Das ist grandios in die Hose gegangen. Da muss man einfach sagen, da hat der Fortuna-Vorstand seine Hausaufgaben so ein bisschen nicht gemacht. Das hat Klaus Alofs auch ziemlich unumwoben auf der Mitgliederversammlung zugegeben. Das heißt, da sollte eine Verpflichtung getätigt werden. Das Budget war aber im Prinzip ausgeschöpft. Man brauchte den Aufsichtsrat nochmal, um das okay zu kriegen. Das sind natürlich Prozesse, die einerseits eingehalten werden müssen. Auf der anderen Seite dauern die am Deadline Day vielleicht ein bisschen zu lange. Und das sorgte dann dafür, dass Simon Zoller mit den Hufen Scharte und beim FC St. Pauli unterschrieb. Kein Vorwurf an den Spieler, kann ich verstehen, wenn die nicht zu Pod kommen in Düsseldorf. Aber das ist natürlich eine kleine Peinlichkeit, die man sich da geleistet hat. Klaus Alofs hat da Gebesserungen gelobt auf der Mitgliederversammlung und gesagt, das wird nicht mehr vorkommen. Glücklicherweise hat sich ja Fermé inzwischen als veritabler Torjäger entpuppt. Aber ein Faktor ist auch, wenn Fermé nicht dabei ist und er ist zum Beispiel gegen Wien, Wiesbaden und Fürth. Das waren die zwei Niederlage in Folge, die wir in dieser Hinrunde unter anderem hatten. Da war er nicht dabei, wegen einer Gehirnerschütterung. Daniel Ginczek ist verletzt, weil Daniel Ginczek leider in der späten Phase seiner Karriere fast immer verletzt ist. Und dann fehlt uns ein Mittelstürmer und der ist vor unserem System durchaus relevant. Das hat die Abwesenheit von Fermé gezeigt. Und das sagt man im Prinzip auch ganz oft bei der Fortuna. Das wird die Position sein, wo man sich jetzt umguckt im Winter und wo was passieren wird und sollte, damit das in der Rückrunde vielleicht etwas besser wird spielerisch. Ansonsten muss ich sagen, gerade wenn auch Leute wie Zimmermann oder Hoffmann wieder da sind, sehe ich uns halt auch defensiv stabil. Wie gesagt, auch jetzt schon die drittwenigsten Gegentore. Und über die Offensive mache ich mir aktuell nicht so viele Sorgen. Also das wäre auf jeden Fall ein wichtiger Faktor. In einer perfekten Welt vielleicht noch ein Außenverteidiger, aber ich bin mir sicher, das reicht nicht.
Ja, also Entschuldigung. Also ist ja schon nicht so, dass Mittelstürmer wie Sand am Meer wüchsen und Außenverteidiger im Fußball. Also jetzt wirst du vermessen. Aber gut, wir werden es...
Am besten noch einen linken, ne?
Ja, genau. Genau.
Genau, genau. Damit wir nicht immer unsere ehemaligen Stürmer da einsetzen müssen mit Emmanuel Llor, der das aber ziemlich gut macht.
Also ihr müsst froh sein, wenn nicht Verme irgendwie fürs nächste Länderspiel in der Nationalmannschaft berufen wird. So sehr sind Mittelstürmer gerade gefragt. Ach verdammt, ja, na klar. Ich bin ja so dumm. So viel dazu. Toll. Einfach wahnsinnig, wie ich mich auskenne in der 2. Liga. Aber dafür habe ich ja euch. Wir gucken uns an, wie es bei Fortuna weitergeht. Und ihr habt jetzt mitbekommen, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, am Samstag um 13.30 Uhr, wenn Fortuna zu Hause gegen... Sonntag! Ja genau, Samstag um 13.30 Uhr. Genau. Soweit kommt es noch. Ich bin anscheinend ein bisschen durch.
Nicht, dass die Leute alle zu früh da sind, dann ist dann noch das Tor zu.
Ach so, ja ehrlich gesagt hätte ich jetzt eher gedacht, sie schalten ein. Rasenfunk-Publikum ist eher so Sofapublikum. Seien wir so ehrlich, müssen wir sein. Die zählen dann Flanken.
Ja, wir sind tatsächlich eher ein Stadion-Podcast.
Jaja, das finde ich ja auch sehr, sehr gut. Da bekommt man auch den Wurst-Test noch mit. Da gab es früher mal ein ganzes Blog zu. Ich weiß gar nicht mehr, wie das hieß.
Ja, aber sehr schön, dass du die Wurst der Woche, so heißt das bei uns, dass du sie kennst.
Ja, die Wurst der Woche, das ist hier in München anders bedacht. Das hat oft mit dem FC Bayern zu tun. Aber das ist ein anderes Thema. Ich habe schon eine Minute hingen, dieses Öde auf einmal. Keine Ahnung, gerade habe ich das Gefühl, ich möchte gendern. Ich weiß gar nicht wieder, was da gerade passiert ist. Egal, anderes Thema innen. Also Fortuna Düsseldorf, 4. Platz. Wir schauen, wie es nach dem Spiel gegen Kiel aussieht. Und wir gehen weiter in unsere Runde. Wir gehen weiter in der Tabelle. Wir sehen, Furt ist auch noch gut mit dabei. Punktgleich mit Düsseldorf. Dann Elbersberg, wir wussten aber natürlich alle, das wäre nur von kurzer Dauer, deswegen wollen wir nicht über die reden. Hannover, Hertha, Wiesbaden und dann mit 21 Punkten der SCP aus Paderborn. Punktgleich mit Nürnberg, Wiesbaden und Hertha. Also alle vier Vereine haben 21 Punkte. Es geht eng zu da. Immerhin ist man fünf Punkte vor den Relegationsplätzen, aber auch ein ganzes Stück hinter dem Relegationsplatz nach oben, nämlich sieben Punkte zurück. Wenn ich mir jetzt aber so den Saisonverlauf angucke, Kevin, und auch die Ergebnisse jetzt mal ausgenommen, natürlich dieses von uns allen erwarteten Siegs in Düsseldorf, dann glaube ich, ist man halbwegs froh, dass man da so in der Mitte steht inzwischen, oder?
Eigentlich nicht so wirklich. Also, ich glaube, man könnte es anders ausdrücken, sollte vielleicht froh sein, ich weiß es nicht. Und beziehungsweise vor allem, dass Braunschweig und Osnabrück ja quasi schon abgestiegen sind. Insofern, dann könnte halt der Relegationsplatz gefährlich werden, aber Schalke tut alles dafür, unten dran zu bleiben. Nein, also, es ist eine wirklich sehr durchwachsene, so eine ganz schwierige, was viele im Umfeld so gar nicht irgendwie realisiert haben, glaube ich, lange Zeit. Wobei auch das Gemäcker im Sommer groß war, dass man tätig werden muss im Sturm und so weiter. Nachdem Pieringer zum FC Schalke zurückgegangen war und dann halt nach Heidenweim weitergereicht wurde für Schleppe, ich weiß gar nicht, zwei Millionen Euro. Das hätten wir, glaube ich, gerade auch noch hinbekommen, hätte man uns das angeboten. Er wollte halt in die Bundesliga und dann natürlich der große Adalaz Schallenberg weg, Justwahn weg nach Hoffenheim, wo er ja richtig durchgestartet ist. Und dann natürlich noch unsere Leihgabe vom FC Chelsea, der dann auch zurück zum FC Chelsea gegangen ist und jetzt irgendwo in der Second Division spielt. Für uns schwere Verluste, ganz, ganz schwierige Sorts, droht der nächste Abgang im Winter. Der einzige verbleibende Unterschiedsspieler, den wir noch haben. Von denen wird der Hart gerüchtet, zum VfB Stuttgart gelotst zu werden.
Ach, okay.
Von unserem ehemaligen sportlichen Leiter, wo Herrn Wohlgemuth. Mal gucken, ob das so ist.
Dem ist man wohl nicht mehr so Wohlgemuth.
Der war gut. Man arbeitet seit einem halben Jahr mit Hochdruck dran, Musliya zu verlängern. Irgendeiner Form, wahrscheinlich mit einer Klausel drin. Ich weiß nicht, wie viel man da drauflegen könnte. Es scheint ihn nicht zu überzeugen. So steht diese ganze Sau auch immer im Schatten der Personalien bei uns bisher. Eine Mannschaft, die mit vielen neuen jungen Spielern dazugekommen ist, mit einem tollen Aufstieg der U21, der für uns momentan elementar wichtig ist, den wir uns lange Jahre herbeigesehen haben und der uns jetzt frische Talente liefert, die jetzt aufgrund der Liganähe, also die jetzt nicht mehr in der Oberliga kicken, sondern ein bisschen höher, auch direkt helfen können. Wenn man den letzten Spieltag sieht, hatten wir zwei 19-Jährige im Kader, der eine davon vom FC Schalke gekommen im Sommer. Hansen ist quasi das Stammspieler bei uns. Seit dem zweiten oder dritten Spieltag, ich weiß gar nicht jetzt gerade, aus dem Kopf. Elias Anser war da im Kader gegen Hannover 96, 19 Jahre. Und der gute Kollege Floto, den auch schon alle kennen, die haben bisher beide eigentlich eher in der U21, in der Regionalliga, für Aufsehen gesorgt. Und dann hatten wir auf der Bank noch einen Herrn Enz, auch aus der U21. Das heißt, Quassenjürg hat nachdem wir in Elbersberg das Debakel der Saison erlebt hatten, ordentlich durchgemischt, sieben neue Spieler reingesetzt und dann auch unseren Kapitänen aus dem Tor rausgeschmissen. Plus Platte raus, plus schlag mich tot. Also da waren einige nicht in der Startformation. Wir sind da mit sieben neuen Mann gegen Hannover 96 aufgelaufen. Ja, das jetzt quasi von hinten aufgerollt. Ansonsten war der Saisonstart wie immer. Ich wusste, dass wir, wenn wir gegen Fürth spielen, zum Auftakt verlieren werden. Denn so wie wir gegen Hannover immer gewinnen, verlieren wir immer gegen Reuter Fürth. Wir haben, glaube ich, in über 20 Spielen noch nie gegen Fürth gewonnen. Das Frankenland, was ich eh schon nicht so gern mag, noch unsympathischer erscheint als, da wir auch gegen den ersten Heft in Nürnberg eine verheerende Bilanz haben.
Das scheint so ein NRW-Ding zu sein. Denn bis auf dieses Nürnberg-Spiel haben wir auch regelmäßig, eigentlich auch diese Saison in Fürth, verlieren wir immer. Und auch in Nürnberg, zum Beispiel, letzte Saison aus dem Pokal rausgeflogen, in der Liga verloren. Das scheint ein NRW-Ding zu sein.
Ja, aber das kann ja gar nicht sein, dass wir allzu viele Teams haben, weil ansonsten würden die ja die ganze Zeit aufsteigen.
Das ist halt kurios. Aber die haben uns dann fünf eingeschränkt. Wir haben natürlich auch direkt nach ein paar Minuten mit der roten Karte in die Saison.
Stimmt, dass war das am ersten Spieltag, ne?
Dann haben wir gegen Osnabrück auch noch nur 1-1 gespielt. Unfassbar. Und dann durften wir am dritten Spieltag den Sieg feiern. Gegen Düsseldorf. Das ging dann ein bisschen holprig weiter. Und so richtig gut wurde es eigentlich erst, als wir Schalke dann quasi echt daher gespielt haben in Paderborn. Also es war schon, es war mit Abstand die beste Leistung zu dem Zeitpunkt der Mannschaft. Schalke hatte nicht den Hauch einer Chance hier in Paderborn. Das war beachtlich. Und dann haben wir auch eine gute Serie gestartet, haben einmal in Berlin verloren, aber ansonsten dann ja im DFB-Bokal Freiburg rausgeschmissen, haben dann noch in Karlsruhe gewonnen. Und dann die erste Niederlage gegen Nürnberg natürlich, war klar, ein 1 zu 3 kassiert und dann ging das wieder so ein bisschen, ja, Elversberg dann 4-1. Dann war das hier auf einmal, nachdem man vor Nürnberg noch gesagt hatte, wir sind nur drei Punkte hinter dem Aufstiegsplatz, war das auf einmal im Mittelfeld und ist der Trainer noch der Richtige. Und dann kam der Trainer sieben Spieler raus, verlängert seinen Vertrag und gewinnt 1-0 gegen Hannover 96 in der 91. Spielminute durch den Kollegen Muslia, der eigentlich eine Flanke geschlagen hat, wo keiner dran gegangen ist und der Ball ins Tor geht.
Ah, Fußball, einfach so eine schöne Sportart. Und ich meine, gut, jetzt im DFB-Pokal gegen Leverkusen war Schluss, also zwei von drei hier aus der Runde haben es geschafft, aber das ist ja jetzt auch nicht so überraschend tatsächlich. Gegen Leverkusen kann gerade niemand bestehen. Aber du musst mir bitte noch mal diesen Switch erklären vom Elbersberg-Spiel hin zum Hannover-Spiel. Was bedeutet denn, sieben Leute rausgeschmissen, also rausrotiert auf die Bank oder?
Ja, größtenteils auf die Bank rotiert. Also fangen wir mal an mit der Pressekonferenz nach Elbersberg, wo der Trainer zum ersten Mal öffentlich die Mannschaft nicht mehr geliebt hat. Er spricht immer von, er liebt die Jungs, er liebt die Mannschaft und hat dann auch gesagt, dass er das ja immer sagen würde und sich vor die Mannschaft stellen würde. Und jetzt wäre es auch mal erlaubt, dass er jetzt im Folgesatz die Mannschaft auch mal quasi niederreißen wird und hat dann auch namentlich Spieler genannt. Er hat dann namentlich auch Spieler genannt, die ihre Leistung nicht gebracht haben. In den Wochen allgemein in den letzten Wochen hat er Janik Hult sehr oft genannt, unser Torhüter, und der ist dann ja auch auf die Bank gegangen. Jetzt in Leverkusen war er gar nicht mehr im Kader. Allerdings da offenbar aus persönlichen Gründen, die ihn kurz vor der Abreise ein Telefonat erreicht hatte, deswegen ja nicht. Dann ist er aus dem Bus gesprungen. Dann hat die U21 gerade nebenan trainiert und dann ist der Torwart da als Ersatztorwart mitgefahren. Genau, das war das. In einem Spiel, Kind Zombie raus, Platte raus. Ich krieg sie gar nicht alle zusammen. Außer ihnen Verteidigung, zwei, drei Leute. Alle auf die Bank und dann, wie gesagt, zwei Leute aus der U21 in die Startformation gestellt. Den anderen 19-Jährigen auch und noch einen auf die Bank. Und den neuen Torwart, der sein einziges Spiel bisher gemacht hat, in Freiburg im DFB-Pokal. Und dann mit der Ansage vor dem Spiel auf der Pressekonferenz, dass es halt Spieler sein müssen, die sich hundertprozentig identifizieren mit der Aufgabe, bevor das Gefühl hat, dass sie ihn weiterbringen. Das würde zu weit führen, wenn ich die Sätze alle nacheinander zitiere, aber die Pressekonferenz hatte mich schon bestärkt in meiner Vermutung, dass der ordentlich rotieren wird. Und dann habe ich die Aufstellung gegen Hannover gesehen und dachte, wow, krass. Das ist mutig. Geht natürlich auch nur, wenn du nach zwei so heftigen Spielen die Rückendeckung kriegst, indem dein Vertrag verlängert wird als Trainer. Sprich, es wirkte alles so, als hätte er das auch dann mit den Vereinswahlen abgestimmt. Ich werde jetzt den Kapitän rausnehmen, den Vizekapitän rausnehmen. Das heißt, ja, das Sprache, was er selber vor der Saison ernannte, ist quasi degradiert worden. Und ich werde jetzt die jungen Leute aufstellen. Klingt irgendwo auch dann wieder nach letztem Strohhalm. Wenn das nicht funktioniert, wird es eng. Wenn die arrivierten Spieler dann sagen, ja, Kollege, ohne uns klappt es auch nicht. Jetzt musst du mal schauen. Haben sie aber nicht so. Und dann hat er nach dem Spiel, nach dem 1-0, auf der Pressekonferenz gesagt, da wurde er gefragt, was ist denn mit Yannick Huth und Co., wieso haben die den jetzt alle nicht gespielt. Da hat er gesagt, ja, es gibt halt auch Spieler, für die ist das irgendwann nichts Besonderes mehr, in der 2. Bundesliga zu spielen. Das ist für die normal. Das ist auch völlig okay. Aber solche Spieler müssen dann halt mehr als 100 Prozent bringen. Und ansonsten steht halt jemand dahinter, der wartet drauf. Und der hat richtig Bock und ist geil drauf, in der 2. Liga zu spielen. Was ja quasi damit äußert, dass der Stammtorwart und Kapitän offenbar die 2. Liga als nichts Besonderes mehr angesehen hat. Könnte man reininterpretieren zum Beispiel.
Ja, also ich frage mich jetzt gerade, woran man das an einem Torhüter dann merken würde, ehrlich gesagt, beim Torhüterspiel, das ist jetzt so das eine.
Ich dachte immer mal, Wiederspiele, wo das so in die Kritik geriet, da hat er Böcke drin gehabt. Dann wirkt er, er hat einfach ein Problem, er ist nicht so öffentlichkeitsgeil, sagen wir mal so. Oder er ist als Kapitän auch nicht so gern ein Sprachrohrer. Er nimmt nicht gerne Interviews an, er ist bei Medienterminen nicht gern dabei, also bei Sponsoren-Terminen oder solche Sachen, irgendwelche Drehs für das Vereins-TV oder so, das macht er alles nicht gerne. Ist ja auch sein gutes Recht, muss er ja nicht mögen, aber als Kapitän ist das halt schwierig. Wenn du bei Interviews nicht zusagst, zum Beispiel im Sommer wollte er auch nicht in den Padergast kommen, also solche Sachen halt. Dann ist das, irgendwann kann dir das auf den Fuß fallen, wenn dann irgendwas nicht mehr so ganz stimmt. Das ist einfach so. Von einem Kapitän erwarte ich, also Uwe Hünemeyer zum Beispiel, hat das alles wahrgenommen. Er hat das als Pflichtaufgabe gesehen für einen Kapitän, sich auch abseits des Spielplatzes zur Mannschaft zu äußern, davor zu stellen, auch gerade wenn es schlecht läuft, sich da hinzustellen und dann das Wort zu ergreifen. Das ist so ein bisschen sein Manko. Ich glaube, das ist jetzt das, was ihm halt letztendlich so ein bisschen ausgelegt wird, als hat er keinen Bock.
Ich meine, extrem schwierig von außen zu beurteilen, aber die Maßnahme ist definitiv drastisch. Und dann stellt das auf jeden Fall Folgefragen. Dass jetzt Lukas Kwasniok auf junge Spieler setzt, das wundert mich gar nicht. Ich meine, der hat beim KSC im Nachwuchsbereich gearbeitet. Auch die Art und Weise, wie er jetzt über diese jungen Spieler spricht, das ist auch schlüssig zu dem Lukas Kwasniok, den ich vor drei oder vier Jahren, glaube ich, mal im Schlüsselspieler-Podcast gehört habe. Da hat er genau darüber gesprochen, was man im Nachwuchsfußball falsch machen würde, dass den den Spielern zu sehr dahinter gepudert würde.
Das passt ja auch zum Verein.
Genau, aber jetzt kommt das große Aber. Du hast selber schon gesagt, wirkt ein bisschen wie der letzte Strohhalm. Du hast auch gesagt, das 1-0 gegen Hannover war erwartbar, weil es ist Hannover und es war eine Flanke, die irgendwie ins Tor gefallen ist. Also das spricht er jetzt auch nicht dafür, dass sich dadurch auf dem Feld so viel verändert hätte. Ach ja, stimmt, genau, das stimmt. Da gab es ja noch... Ich habe auch noch rot gesehen. Also hat sich denn auch spielerisch etwas verändert, weil du vorhin ja auch schon angedeutet hast, die defensive Ausrichtung zum Beispiel in Düsseldorf war überraschend für euch.
Ja, die ist überraschend und wir redeten bis heute, wo die herkommt, beziehungsweise wir haben es in Paderkass versucht zu ergründen, dass das daherkommen könnte, dass man diese Saison davor sehr großen, sehr schönen Hurra-Fußball gespielt hat, aber trotzdem immer kurz vor knapp gescheitert ist, weil man Spiele gegen die großen Teams, zum Beispiel gegen die Favoritenteams verloren hat. Also da hat man regelmäßig die Liga gerockt, aber wenn es dann darum ging, gegen den HSV, also Düsseldorf ausgeklemmert, aber gegen den HSV und Co. zu spielen, hat man diese Spiele meistens verloren. Gegen Heidenheim, gegen Darmstadt damals und so weiter und so fort. Das waren immer Spiele, die wir verloren haben. Und ich tippe mal, dass Lukas Krasniak einfach die Idee hatte, hinten jetzt ein bisschen solider zu stehen, nicht mehr so viele Gegentore zu kassieren, aus der Defensive heraus einfach die Mannschaft weiterzuentwickeln. Also, dass man noch eine weitere Facette dazulernt. Das ist beim SCP halt dann immer wie so eine Operation am offenen Herzen, weil da hast du nicht die... Also, die Spieler werden halt im Sommer über den Sommer hinweg weggekauft und dann musst du halt gucken, wen du dann dafür hast. Den musst du ja auch erst mal alle wieder eingewöhnen.
Ihr habt immer sehr viele Transfers im Sommer, ne? Also, wenn man sich das anguckt, das sind ja immer zehn neue und 18 gegangen, Minimum.
Guck mal und guck jeden Sommer.
Also, es ist eigentlich...
Ja, das war unter Baumgart schon so. Das ist ja auch im Endeffekt inzwischen unser Image, wo der Verein ja auch hin wollte. Vom grauen Nichts zu immerhin hin zum Ausbildungsverein mit einem guten Image für junge Spieler oder irgendwo anders gescheiterte Spieler, die nochmal angreifen wollen. Das ist ja auch voll okay. Nur wenn halt so wie diesen Sommer drei Leitwölfe weggeholt werden, also quasi die Achse im Zentrum komplett weg ist, ist das halt ein enormer Verlust, den man von außen so nicht erst mal feststellt, weil in Schallenberg auf Schalke große Probleme hat. Ich wusste, wann in Hoffenheim schon in Vergessenheit geraten ist für Leute, die ihn aus Paderborn kannten. Und so weiter und so fort. Aber in Paderborn ist das halt ein riesen Impact gewesen. Und du holst halt ein Muslio dazu, als hoffnungsvoller, erfahrener Innenverteidiger, der dann entführt nach fünf Minuten oder drei Minuten direkt die rote Karte bekommt als Debitant. Ja, super, drei Spiele gesperrt ist. Und das war es, Jan ist heuer. Entdeckung der letzten Säuer in der Verteidigung verletzt sich im Sommer kurz oder gegen Ende der letzten Säuer. Und es war jetzt in Leverkusen auf der Bank. Bis dahin ein Spiel oder zwei gemacht. Und drei Kurzeinsätze und immer wieder Rückschläge gehabt. Fällt komplett aus die ganze Zeit. Dann ist er sehr quem aus Freiburg geholt. Ein junger linker Verteidiger, auf einmal mysteriös verletzt, ist zum SC Freiburg zurückgekehrt und seitdem auch nicht wieder hier aufgetaucht. Keine Ahnung, was er hat. Maxi Rohr, vom HSV losgeeist. War ja ganz komisch. Da haben sich ja viele gewundert, wieso der vom HSV zum SCP wechselt. Hat aber eine alte Verbundenheit mit dem Trainer. Und spielt eine gute letzte Saison. Er hat sich in der Rückrunde quasi auch zum Stammspieler entwickelt. Und dann hatten wir in den Paderkassen, haben mit ihm ein tolles Gespräch gehabt über seine Zeit, als er ein junges Talent war, wo er dann mit Fußball aufgehört hat. Auf einmal. Und Profi-Fußball war keine Option mehr. Und ist dann irgendwie wieder über Umwege zurückgekommen, über die Landesliga oder schlagt mich tot. Und ist auf einmal bei uns verschwunden am Anfang. Keiner wusste genau, wieso. Er hatte eine Verletzung, hatte dann, die aber niemals so lange dauern konnte. Also nach zwei Wochen irgendwie wäre die eigentlich weg gewesen. Ist aber nicht mehr zurückgekehrt. Und ja, Lukas Krasniuk hat das am letzten Spieltag auf einmal in so einem Nebensatz erwähnt, was ich auch gut fand, weil man das nicht so zum Thema gemacht hat, dass er mental halt krank war. Und Maxi Rohr hatte wieder, also zum zweiten Mal in seiner Karriere, quasi keinen Spaß mehr an Fußball, so oder konnte nicht mehr seine Leistung bringen. Und so zieht sich das jetzt durch. Jetzt habe ich ja schon vier Spieler aus dem Defensivbereich genannt. Dann hast du die Stürmer, die alle verletzt waren im Sommer. Also es waren ja alle Stürmer verletzt. Felix Platter ist ja auch eigentlich dauerhaft verletzt, immer wieder leider. Aber sonst wäre er auch nicht nach Paderborn zurückgekehrt. Und das ist halt so die Saison. Also das ist echt schwierig. Er hat auch von einer solchen Saison gesprochen, Kwasniok. Trotzdem schafft die Mannschaft, immer wieder gute Spiele hinzulegen. Nur da fehlt halt komplett die Konstanz. Das ist halt leider einfach so.
Und wie müsste die Saison jetzt verlaufen, dass sie noch ein Erfolg wäre? Weil unter den Umständen kann es ja nicht darum gehen, jetzt irgendwie die Top 3 anzugreifen.
Nee, kann es in dieser Saison auch nicht. Also ein Erfolg wäre sie wirklich, wenn du jetzt im oberen Bereich dich rein, also in ruhige Fahrwasser kommst, ein bisschen weniger Gegentore auch fängst, also nicht immer so Ausreißer drin hast, wurde wieder 5 fängs. Wir haben jetzt echt bis zum Spiel gegen Nürnberg hatten wir die endlich. Ich weiß nicht, am 13. Spieltag haben wir die Tordifferenz auf Null ausgeglichen. Das hing von Fürth immer noch nach vorm ersten Spieltag und jetzt haben wir sie wieder bei minus 4 durch diese unsäglichen zwei Niederlagen, 3-1 und 4-1. Also wie kann das gelingen? Jetzt haben wir ein ganz einfaches Spiel vor der Brust, am Samstag in Hamburg. Ich glaube, das wäre sogar so ein Spiel, was wir wieder gewinnen könnten. Gerne, glaube ich, gegen den HSV und unseren ehemaligen, auch damals schweren Verlust Schonlau, der dann direkt Kapitän wurde beim HSV. Ich weiß nicht, was dazu führen kann. Ich bin gespannt, was im Winter passiert. Personalmann wird sicherlich nochmal was tun. Ich habe auch gehört, wenn Musli nach Stuttgart geht oder wohin auch immer, werden wir das Geld nutzen und drei bis vier neue Spieler holen. Nicht, weil alle so schlecht sind, sondern weil viele halt ständig verletzt sind. Das ist ein bisschen so wie bei der Fortuna, nur dass da halt ein gewachsener Raus gerüst ist, wo vielleicht nicht so viel Adalas war. Wobei ich auch da immer fasziniert bin. Ich habe da glaube ich schon seit Jahren immer den kleinsten Kader.
Genau, also das ist noch der große Unterschied. Paderborn hat aktuell einen 30er Kader und Fortuna Düsseldorf 24.
Ich bin gespannt, was unsere jungen Wilden da reißen werden in der Saison. Ich bin da sehr fasziniert von. Ich liebe das, wenn diese jungen Spieler eingebaut werden, weil da echt tolle Typen bei sind. Und denen macht es halt auch Spaß, zuzugucken. Da bin ich dann auch cool damit, wenn die mal zwei, drei verlieren oder so. Solange die kämpfen und ein schönes Spiel spielen, finde ich das super. Wenn das dann so wie gegen Elbersberg ist, wo quasi du in der zweiten Halbzeit das Gefühl hast, dass Elbersberg Zweitligist ist und du so maximal Landesligist bist, was das Defensivverhalten angeht, dann wird es kritisch. Das war wirklich Selbstaufgabe. Da haben wir Glück gehabt in Elbersberg, dass wir nicht 8-1 oder so untergegangen sind, weil Elbersberg hatte, als sie das 4-1 geschossen haben, danach mindestens noch zwei oder drei hundertprozentige Chancen, wo unsere Verteidiger einfach zugeguckt haben. Sie sind nach dem 4-1 unsere Defensive komplett, wie man das selbst kennt, wo man früher selbst gespielt hat, wenn man in der Kreisliga quasi 6-0 zurück lag, hatte man auch keinen Bock mehr und so standen die da auch und Elbersberg ist weiter marschiert. Also das war kurz davor, ein richtiges Debakel zu werden. Und dann wäre es für einen Coach, glaube ich, richtig eng geworden.
Elbersberg ist aber auch echt spielstark. Das muss man auch mal sagen. Die spielen einen Superball. Die haben in Lautern auch einen Superball gespielt. Die sind natürlich, das ist ähnlich, wie es in Lautern letztes Jahr war, die sind natürlich so ein bisschen von der Euphorie getragen. Ich bin mal gespannt, wie es in der Rückrunde weitergeht. Aber was die auf den Platz bringen, ist echt aller Ehren wert.
Absolut. Das war das. Ich habe uns auch da wiedererkannt, also ein paar Jahre zurück, als wir auf einmal diesen wilden Offensiv-Fußball gespielt haben, der so das Überfall-artige, Ruck-artige hat. Das haben die jetzt auch voll drin. Und das hattet ihr tatsächlich auch in der letzten Saison, auf dem Betze vor allem. Das macht halt auch Spaß. Das musste ich auch neidlos anerkennen. Also ich meine, ich habe davor die Woche den Schalke-Podcast gehört, von den Journalisten-Kollegen. Ich weiß gerade nicht, wer heißt, 19 und irgendwas. Ich glaube 1904 Minuten oder so. Da haben die, da regen die sich regelmäßig auf. Also war ja Schalke nur noch, also kann man sich fast nur noch. Und da haben die gesagt, da stand die dann so. Und dann gesagt, wir haben gegen Elbersberg zu Hause verloren. Wir haben vor Jahresfrist noch gegen den FC Bayern München gespielt. Die haben vor zwei Jahren noch vor 400 Zuschauern gespielt. Wir haben gegen Elbersberg verloren. Bei allem Respekt, das kann es nicht sein. Wenn man dann mal überlegt, was hat Schalke gesagt, hat Schalke vor vier Jahren noch Champions, was waren die Vizemeister Champions League? Irgendwas, keine Ahnung. Erschreckend.
Ja, Vizemeister.
Muss ich sagen, wenn Schalke da gegen die 2. Bundesliga verliert, können wir auch mal Vizemeister verlieren.
Das ist der Spirit. Wahrscheinlich war es 1904 der Schalke-Talk, aber genauer weiß ich das nicht.
Das ist ganz witzig. Ich kenne die Kollegen auch. Deswegen ist das noch witziger, wie die da jedes Mal verzweifeln. Gut, jetzt haben sie ja gewonnen, aber sonst ist das ganz unterhaltsam, sich anzukommen.
Du, Kevin, ich hätte aber eine Frage. Das ist jetzt einfach so ein Thema, das haben wir auch bei uns im Podcast so ein bisschen besprochen vor dem Paderborn-Spiel. Weil du gerade sagtest, Lucas Quasniok, für ihn könnte es dann auch eng werden. Ich kann mich erinnern, im Sommer, da war diese Angelegenheit auf Mallorca, wo er verhaftet wurde. Inzwischen wurde das Verfahren eingestellt. Allerdings, das kennen wir ja auch von größeren deutschen Bands, da werden auch Verfahren eingestellt. Möglicherweise fragt man sich, ob das denn alles so vernünftig ist. Ist da eigentlich was hängen geblieben von? Weil das wird natürlich, logischerweise, nicht vom SC Paderborn weiter thematisiert. Aber im Prinzip war es das danach. Das ist mein Gefühl von außen, nachdem diese Beleidigung kam.
Da ist tatsächlich nichts mehr hängen geblieben. Es spricht keiner mehr drüber. Es ist immer nur mal wieder von außen die Frage. Man selber stellt sich natürlich auch manchmal die Frage, was ist eigentlich jetzt da wirklich gewesen? Oder war das jetzt so, wie das jetzt dargestellt wurde am Ende, dass es nichts war oder zumindest nichts juristisch Unsauberes war? Ich weiß gerade nicht, wie ich es richtig ausdrücken soll. Also, unfreiwilliges So. Ja, das ist tatsächlich nicht hängen geblieben. Ich glaube, das würde ihm auch nicht mehr zum Vorwurf gemacht, denn jetzt hätte man nach Eversberger die Chance gehabt, dann einen sportlichen Grund zu haben, um ihn zu entlassen. Und man muss ja sagen, er ist da so eine Art, er spricht auch gerne mal vom wandelnden Kamel und er kann das sehr gut, er hat sich sehr gut, er hat sich sehr, also als Trainer zumindest, muss ich sagen, persönlich kenne ich ihn ja nicht, hat er sich sehr gut entwickelt. Er hat sich durch diese ganzen Sachen medial auch sehr, sich sehr geformt. Man erinnere sich ja daran, es gab ja auch sehr viel Diskussionen um ihn als Trainer, dass er sich nicht hart impfen lassen während der Corona-Zeit. Außer dann, als die USA-Reise anstand und er dann gesagt hat, im Dienste der Mannschaft, also für die Mannschaft, für dieses Trainingssager, würde er das jetzt machen. Also das hatte, da ist er schon drüber fast gestolpert damals. Da hat er sehr viele Kritiker gehabt im Umfeld des Vereins auch und ja auch deutschlandweit. Wenigst hat er seinen Pass nicht gefälscht, seinen Impfpass. Und dann halt diese Geschichte, das war ja sogar letzte Saison noch vor dem letzten Spieltag, wo er dann am letzten Spieltag gar nicht mehr auf der Bank saß, wo alle auch dachten, das war es jetzt. Auch das hat er geschafft. Jetzt hat er die nächste Höhle geschafft. Und er committet sich ja unfassbar stark zu diesem Verein. Er sprach jetzt sogar davon nach der Vertragsverlängerung, dass er deswegen so Vereine lieben würde. Und das wären ja genauso Vereine wie Freiburg, Heidenheim und Co., die in jeder Lage der sportlichen Leitung den Rücken stärken und sich deswegen auch nur so entwickeln konnten über die Jahre. Quasi aus dem Nichts heraus zu Vereinen, die dann, ja, nur weil Spiele, da hat er übrigens den Satz auch wieder genannt, nur weil bestimmte Spieler keine Lust haben oder schlechte Laune verbreiten, dass dann dafür nicht die sportliche Führung ausgetauscht wird, sondern eine sportliche Führung festgehalten wird. Was wiederum meine Info, dass im Winter vielleicht nochmal nachgebessert wird, auch nochmal bestärken könnte.
Das werden wir dann sehen. Und jetzt haben wir auch schon die perfekte Brücke, um über den ersten FC Kaiserslautern zu sprechen. Denn da ist es ja nicht so, dass festgehalten wurde am Trainer. Und das musst du mir jetzt als allererstes mal erklären, Sebastian. Also, Dimitrius Kramotsis ist jetzt Trainer. Er hat auch insofern einen erfolgreichen Einstieg gehabt, als man jetzt im DFB-Pokal gegen den 1. FC Nürnberg weitergekommen ist. Also man steht im Viertelfinale sowieso. DFB-Pokal, aktuell Geisterwettbewerb. Schaut euch die Viertelfinalisten an. Nehmen auch irgendwie die paar Erstligisten raus. Und wir haben nur noch Spaß alle. Also es ist ja absolut fantastisch. Aber erklär mir mal bitte, Sebastian, warum musste Dirk Schuster gehen? Denn von der Tabellenkonstellation her, bis auf die Niederlagenserie am Schluss, konnte man das nicht nachvollziehen von außen.
Ich habe das vorhin durchaus ernst gemeint, als ich gesagt habe, dass dieses Düsseldorf-Spiel, glaube ich, wirklich entscheidend war. Weil du zum einen einfach einen extremen moralischen Tiefschlag hattest, nachdem du nach so einer stabilen Führung dieses Spiel noch verlierst. Zum anderen diese ganze Geschichte drumherum mit diesem Flaschenwurf noch. Und dann verletzt sich ein Ragnar Acher, der wirklich in Lautern eingeschlagen hat, wie eine Bombe. Also das sind wirklich auch so ein paar Spieler, wo Thomas Hengen, der Sportchef oder der Hauptvereinsboss, ein echt glückliches Händchen bewiesen hat, die in Lautern plötzlich, warum auch immer, funktionieren. Richmond sagt liebe Grüße.
Ja, aber den Ragnar Ache, habe ich im Sommer gesagt, soll der Markus Koschke Felix aus Frankfurt nach Paderborn schicken, in seine Heimat und nicht zu euch, obwohl er gelandet bei euch ist.
Wir waren auch daneben dran, glaube ich. Man fragt sich wirklich, warum ein Spieler mit der Qualität sich für Lautern entscheidet, aber offenbar hatten sie gute Argumente, ihn zu überzeugen, dass er da was aufbauen kann. Ich glaube, er zahlt es zurück, dass man ihm einfach dieses Vertrauen schenkt und ihn machen lässt. Du hast dann dieses Spiel verloren, du hast deinen Topscorer verloren und du hast wirklich gemerkt, auch wenn natürlich die Verantwortlichen das immer dann bestritten haben, da gab es einfach einen Bruch. Dann gab es danach noch dieses HSV-Spiel, wo du auch eine stabile Führung aus der Hand gibst, das zwar dann nicht verlierst, aber unentschieden spielst. Das waren so zwei Spiele, das hat dann einfach keiner mehr verstanden, wie das sein kann, dass du zwei so deutliche Führungen aus der Hand gibst. Ab dann hat die Formkurve nach unten gezeigt. Die Saison hat mit zwei Niederlagen begonnen. Da hat man schon gewusst, okay, könnte schwierig werden, aber da war es so, das erste Spiel ging direkt gegen Pauli verloren, da war noch so, mal gucken. Aber jetzt sieht man ja, wo Pauli steht. Von daher war als Gradmesser damals schon, okay, kann man irgendwie nachvollziehen. War jetzt auch nicht so, dass man da unterirdisch gespielt hat. Dann hat man auf Schalke verloren, wo man sagen muss, da hat man sich unnötig in Rückstand gebracht, durch rote Karten auch. Hat aber an sich ein spielerisch gutes Spiel gemacht und eigentlich auch in der Höhe unverdient verloren. Also ich sage mal, die Niederlage geht am Ende in Ordnung, aber man hat sich da eigentlich gut verkauft. Und ab dann, ab dem dritten Spieltag, ging es dann wirklich bergauf. Man hat eine Serie gestartet und die Mannschaft hat wirklich, also wirklich entfesselt auch gespielt, hat spielerisch geglänzt, gerade im Offensivbereich. Bis eben zu diesem Düsseldorf-Spiel, wo man auch, da gebe ich Thorsten recht, da hat man sich auch gefragt, was ist denn hier los? Wie kann es denn jetzt hier 3-0 für den SCK stehen? Geht ja gar nicht. Also vom Spielverlauf her war er durch, also auch glücklich. Ja, und dann hätte man aber eigentlich auch gedacht, oder hätte ich auch gedacht, dass die Dirk Schuster noch ein bisschen mehr Zeit geben. Weil es schon so ist in Lautern, wie es, glaube ich, bei vielen Vereinen auch ist. Ich weiß nicht, ich habe auch jetzt bei der Pressekonferenz, als dann Thomas Heng da vor uns Journalisten saß und die Gründe dann erklärt hat, warum man sich von Dirk Schuster getrennt hat, habe ich auch gesagt, wir saßen jetzt hier in den letzten Jahren so oft und es wurde uns was erzählt von, man möchte eine Spielphilosophie entwickeln, man braucht eine gewisse Kontinuität. Und dann habe ich auch mal gefragt, wie sieht es denn aus? Woran hängt das denn, dass hier niemand die Zeit hat, mal was zu entwickeln, oder dass das einfach nicht funktioniert, dass hier mal wirklich mal jemand länger als anderthalb Jahre da ist und die Chance hat, was zu entwickeln? Und andere Vereine, jetzt haben wir gerade über Paderborn gesprochen, da hält man dran fest und versucht dem Trainer wirklich Zeit zu geben, was zu entwickeln und klar, die Beispiele, die dann immer kommen, mit Heidenheim und Freiburg, aber ich finde es auch einfach mal spannend, zu sehen, was dabei rauskommt, wenn jemand längere Zeit was entwickeln kann. Und ich muss sagen, das ist jetzt auch nicht so, es gibt immer ein gespaltenes Lager, es gibt immer Leute, die sagen, der Trainer muss weg, ist immer der Erste, der weg muss. Und es gab tatsächlich, und da sind wir auch wieder bei Elbersberg, Lautern hat ja auch 2-1 hinten gelegen beim Heimspiel gegen Elbersberg, da gab es die ersten schuste Rausrufe damals. Dann hat der FCK das Spiel aber noch gedreht, da waren alle wieder happy. Und dann ist es auch, also meiner Meinung nach, hat der Schuster es auch wirklich geschafft, man hat gesehen, er hat die Mannschaft weiterentwickelt, er konnte die vielen Neuzugänge gut einbauen. Klar, die Defensive war und ist das große Manko, man hat es jetzt im Pokal zum ersten Mal geschafft, diese Saison überhaupt keinen Tor zu fangen, was eigentlich unglaublich ist. Aber es war jetzt nicht so, dass man das Gefühl hatte, da geht gar nichts mehr, aber es war dann wirklich auch so, der FCK hatte dann auch diese extreme englische Woche mit drei Spielen, mit dem Pokalspiel, mit Köln dazwischen, da gab es drei Heimspiele, HSV, dann das Pokalspiel gegen Köln und dann Gräuter Fürth daheim, innerhalb von einer Woche drei Heimspiele, wo man eigentlich denkt, auch so als die Fans, was kann es geileres geben, als innerhalb von einer Woche dreimal zu spielen, davon einmal gegen HSV und einmal gegen den 1. FC Köln, sorry Fürth, aber das waren zwei Spiele, da sind innerhalb von drei Spielen über 120.000 Leute auf den Betzenberg gekommen, zweimal ausverkauft und selbst gegen Fürth auch über 40.000. Das zeigt auch schon, was Dirk Schuster mit der Mannschaft ja auch geschafft hat, nämlich er hat eine unglaubliche Euphorie auch wiederentwickelt. Das ging letzte Saison, in der ersten Saison nach dem Wiederaufstieg aus der dritten Liga los, die Leute hatten wieder Lust, das Feuer ist wieder entfacht. Du hast wirklich gemerkt, wer mal versucht hat, als Otto Normal Mensch eine Karte für ein FCK-Spiel zu bekommen, der guckt ganz schön schnell in die Röhre bei Auswärtsspielen genauso. Da wird immer das komplette Kontingent plus abgerufen. Es ist Wahnsinn, was die Fans da abreißen.
Ihr wart auch letzte Saison beim Heimspiel bei uns. Da wart ihr wirklich auch neben dem HSV mit der größten Menge an Zuschauern vertreten. Ich weiß jetzt nicht, wie viele es waren, aber natürlich auch weit über den Auswärtsblock hinaus.
Ich frage mich da auch immer, wer das genau dann zählt und schätzt, wenn es dann heißt 10.000 oder HSV bei Hertha mit 20.000. Aber es sind auf jeden Fall viele. Jedenfalls lief eigentlich alles sehr, sehr gut. Und dann kam dieser Bruch nach Düsseldorf. Und dann war es auch wirklich unerklärlich, dass die Mannschaft dann teilweise völlig neben sich stand. Es ist nichts mehr zusammengelaufen. Und da muss man halt dann sagen, durch diese Konstante, die du vorne mit Ragnar Ache am Anfang der Saison hattest, das ist wirklich ein Spieler. Ich habe noch selten einen, vor allem in der 2. Liga, einen Spieler gesehen, der jedes Kopfball-Duell gewinnt. Also ich kann mich nicht erinnern, wann Ragnar Ache ein Kopfball-Duell verloren hat. Der steht in der Luft. Und das ist einfach diese physische Präsenz, die der hat, seine Schnelligkeit, sein Antritt, seine Luftstärke. Wahnsinn. Dann fiel der weg. Dann hattest du immer noch einen Terence Boyd, der jetzt wirklich auch kein Unbekannter ist, der auch ein Super-Standing hat bei den Fans, der es natürlich aber schwer hatte, war dann nicht fit. Dann kam Ache, und dann ist es halt einfach schwer. Und die beiden zusammen gingen dann zwar zwischenzeitlich auch mal kurz, aber es sind eigentlich keine zwei Spielertypen, die du zusammenstellen kannst. Das würden die meisten Trainer wahrscheinlich nicht machen. Dann hat Terence Boyd die Chance quasi wieder bekommen, als Ache dann verletzt war. Und dann war es halt einfach brutal schwer. Dann war der FCK in einer Situation, wo er jetzt nicht gerade aus dem Vollen schöpfen konnte, was Chancen anging. Und dann muss halt auch Terence Boyd aus den wenigen Chancen, die er dann kriegt, mal was machen, hat er dann nicht geschafft. Dementsprechend hattest du dann keine Konstante mehr im Angriff. Und dann war es einfach echt schwierig. Aber es hat uns, um das jetzt mal abzurunden, es hat uns alle, auch die Journalisten-Kollegen und mich, sehr überrascht. Der Zeitpunkt war auch komisch, so mitten in der Woche, wo du gesagt hast, eigentlich hättest du dich direkt nach dem vorangegangenen Spiel trennen können, anfangs der Woche, an einem Montag. Aber dann ist das irgendwie so mitten in der Woche, trennst du dich dann, hast dann quasi kaum noch Zeit für das nächste Spiel in Magdeburg. Trittst dann da mit einem Interimsteam an und stellst dann am nächsten Tag den Trainer vor. Der hat dann zwei Tage, sich aufs Pokalspiel vorzubereiten. Also es war schon irre. Und man muss auch sagen, Dimitrios Komotzis hat jetzt einen guten Einstand gehabt. Aber man muss es so deutlich ansprechen, es kann eigentlich nicht so sein, dass Dimitrios Komotzis die 1A-Lösung war. Es sind ja viele Namen gehandelt worden. Die Kollegen vom Kicker hatten ja auch berichtet, dass man sich mit Herrn Wimmer sehr einig war. Es läuft alles darauf raus, dass es nur der Plan gewesen sein kann, dass man Wimmer verpflichten wollte, dass dann aber eben zu früh an die Öffentlichkeit ging und man dann quasi handeln musste. Weil wenn dann mal auf dem Markt ist, dass man sich mit anderen Trainern unterhält, dann kann man natürlich den eigenen Coach schon noch schwer halten. Aber das war einfach alles in allem eine schwierige Situation und passt auch eigentlich nicht zu den Dingen, wobei doch eigentlich passt es doch zu Thomas Hengen, weil er hat ja auch damals kurz vor der Relegation zu den Aufstiegsspielen in die 2. Liga auch die Trainerentscheidung damals getroffen, Marco Antwerpen entlassen und Dirk Schuster geholt. Und der Erfolg hat ihm recht gegeben. Von daher hat er jetzt wieder unkonventionell gehandelt.
Ja, vor allem, was heißt unkonventionell? Also in Lautern am Marstein war das ja wieder Textbook-Lautern. Das ist ja 60 Lautern, Schalke, HSV. Warum macht ihr immer die... Also, ich meine, du hast es ja selber noch mal super rausgearbeitet. Aber ich möchte das noch mal kurz unterstreichen. Als man gegen Düsseldorf dieses Spiel hatte, bei dem man den Bruch hatte, da lag man auf dem dritten Tabellenplatz. Das war am zehnten Spieltag. Als man dann gegen den HSV nur 3 zu 3 gespielt hat als Lautern. Man ist ja immer noch Lautern, es tut mir leid. Da lag man danach immer noch auf dem sechsten Tabellenplatz. Und klar, es wurde dann schlechter. Aber das Schlimme ist doch, wenn du nicht sagen kannst, woran es liegt. Wenn du aber sagen kannst, uns fehlt ein richtig guter Stürmer. Der ist von einer Flasche getroffen worden. Der musste ausgewechselt werden. Mega dumm gelaufen. Ist nicht von einer Flasche getroffen worden?
Doch, er ist von einer Flasche getroffen worden.
Aber das war nicht der Grund für die Auswechslung.
Er hat weitergespielt, er wurde gefragt, ob er weiterspielen will. Da kann man dann auch die Frage stellen, wie verantwortungsvoll war das, den weiterspielen zu lassen. Der hat danach auch recht benommen gewirkt. Aber du wolltest noch was anderes.
Kopfverletzungen im Fußball, genau.
Das ist jetzt nochmal dein Lieblingsthema. Nachwanken.
Das finde ich schon schön, dass Leute hier als Gastgeschenk ihre Flankenstatistik ihres Vereins mitbringen. Danke nochmal, Thorsten. Aber man kann es ja sogar begründen, woran es liegt. Ich kann gerade gar nicht glauben, dass ich ein Plädoyer für Dirk Schuster halte. Ich habe seinen Fußball nie gerne gesehen. Und der Abgang beim FC Augsburg damals war spektakulär. In all seinen Facetten. Aber dennoch will mir das nicht in den Kopf, warum das Lautern so macht. Und warum ich dann auch tatsächlich in Teilen der Berichterstattung, ich habe das alles nur quasi lesen können, was da bei Lautern passiert. Zu viele andere Themen nebenher noch. Und da klang das in vielen Berichten so, ja, naja, irgendwie konnte man es jetzt schon fast erwarten. Lief jetzt nicht so für Schuster. Und ich denke mir so, ja, aber ihr seid doch im 2. Zweitliga-Jahr.
Ja, übrigens, als du vorhin aufgezählt hast, wie gut es lief, nach dem Sieg gegen Hannover, war man sogar über Nacht mal Tabellenführer. Und jetzt kann man sich anschauen, wo der FCK mittlerweile steht. Ich gebe dir da vollkommen recht. Ich glaube, dass man mittlerweile oder das Teile der Fans und vielleicht auch gewisse Leute im Hintergrund des Vereins vielleicht vergessen haben, wo man eigentlich herkommt. Die Sache ist die, es wird so oft zitiert, das zweite Jahr nach Wiederaufstieg ist das Schwerste. Im ersten ist man von der Euphorie getragen worden gerade in der Hinrunde. Und dann, wie es in der Rückrunde schlecht war, aber egal, hat am Ende trotzdem noch locker gereicht. Jetzt bist du in dem zweiten Jahr und musst eigentlich dich dran erinnern, wo kommst du her. Und nichts anderes als der Klassenerhalt kann eigentlich das Ziel sein. Aber natürlich ist es so, das war in der letzten Saison schon so, da hat die Mannschaft in der Hinrunde overperformed. Das weckt natürlich Hoffnung. Gerade bei den Menschen in Kaiserslautern, ich habe das in jedem Podcast, auch immer, wenn ich bei dir bin, Max, rede ich das, glaube ich, hoch und runter. Diese Erwartungshaltung, dieses wo kommt man her? Die Leute kennen das noch. Die Leute kennen die goldenen 90er Jahre. Der FCK ist mehrfacher deutscher Meister und Pokalsieger. Die Leute haben natürlich irgendwo den Anspruch, irgendwann wieder Bundesliga zu spielen. Und vielleicht gibt es da doch auch ein paar Leute, auch ein paar Fußball-Experten, die sagen, vielleicht doch irgendwann gehört der FCK da auch mal wieder hin.
Das wäre ja auch geil, wenn der FCK da spielen würde.
Man muss sich aber bewusst machen, wo man herkommt. Man kommt aus ganz, ganz bitteren Drittliga-Jahren, die den Verein fast zerstört haben. Der FCK stand wirklich kurz vor dem Aus. Du hast vorhin unser Tribütengespräch angesprochen. Thema Insolvenz und so weiter. Also es war wirklich so kurz davor, dass dieser Verein nicht mehr existiert hätte. Oder in der Form nicht mehr existiert hätte. Von daher kann man wirklich nur sagen, Leute, haltet den Ball flach. Auch wenn die Mannschaft durch ihre Spielweise jetzt auch diese Hinrunde zum Teil wieder natürlich Begehrlichkeit geweckt hat. Und ich glaube einfach, dass dann vielleicht im Hintergrund auch Investoren, Sponsoren stehen, die natürlich sagen, sie geben da jede Menge Geld rein. Und sie wollen, was ja irgendwo auch verständlich ist, wenn ich irgendwo so viel Geld investieren würde, würde ich es wahrscheinlich genauso machen oder erwarten. Die wollen natürlich Erfolge sehen. Und die wollen sehen, dass man dann irgendwann doch halt hochgeht und dann kann ich mir vorstellen, dass das dann auch dazu führt, dass man sagt, ja, probieren wir es doch nochmal mit einem anderen Trainer, weil es ist halt einfacher, die arme Sau an der Seitenlinie auszutauschen als die ganze Mannschaft.
Da gibt es sicherlich unterschiedliche Lager, oder? Es gibt ja, bei den einen könnte man auch von Träumen sprechen.
Ja, natürlich.
Und gerade bei Fans, wie du es sagst, ist das, das kann ich auch voll nachvollziehen, das ist ja sogar ein Paderborn jetzt so. Bei uns wurde am zweiten Spieltag die Mannschaft ausgefiffen. Beim ersten Heimspiel. Das muss man sich mal vorstellen. Der SC Paderborn ist finanziell eine der schlecht gebettetsten Mannschaften im Profifußball. Aber ich kann trotzdem natürlich verstehen, wenn man so Jahre hat, wo man dann begeisternden Fußball spielt, also Aufstiegssaison, dann erste Saison und so, dann sind die Fans natürlich auch schnell, dass sie das vielleicht nicht vergessen, aber dass sie halt einfach sagen, boah, geil, das läuft jetzt wirklich gut. Dann wirst du süchtig nach diesen. Ich hab das auch erlebt. Das 1-0 gegen Hannover war so langweilig phasenweise, wo ich gedacht hab, wo ist denn dieser geile Offensivspektakel, dieses Offensivspektakel, was uns jetzt über Jahre ausgemacht hat?
Träumen ist ja auch erlaubt. Und gerade beim Fußball. Also das ist doch das... Kleine Kinder gehen zum ersten Mal ins Stadion, die Augen leuchten und die träumen dann davon, dass die auch irgendwann da auf dem Rasen stehen. Und genauso träumen die Fans davon, dass ihre Mannschaft irgendwann...
Natürlich, du willst nicht...
Es tut mir leid, du willst nicht gegen Kräuter Fürth spielen. Du willst nicht so gut, wie wir sie jetzt hochgeredet haben, du willst nicht gegen Elbersberg spielen, du willst gegen Bayern München... Natürlich wollen die Leute gegen Bayern München spielen. Weil einfach, das ist das. Wir haben eine Generation von Kindern, man kann immer drüber scherzen, es gibt eine Generation von Kindern, die haben seit 10 Jahren keinen anderen Meister gesehen als Bayern. Es gibt eine ganz große Generation von Kindern, die haben den FCK noch nie Bundesligaspielen gesehen, bzw. sehen ihn jetzt zum ersten Mal überhaupt 2. Liga spielen. Aber die kriegen immer erzählt. Vom Papa, vom Opa, vom Onkel, von der Familie. Na, wie war das damals, als wir die Bayern geschlagen haben, als wir deutscher Meister waren? Und hier Fritz Walter, der Beste aller Zeiten. Natürlich, das ist einfach auch eine unglaubliche Bürde, diese erfolgreiche Vergangenheit. Das habe ich auch schon gebetsmühlenartig oft erzählt in Podcasts. Es ist super, es ist wahnsinnig spannend und toll, dass der Verein diese bewegende Geschichte hat. Das habe ich, habe mich gerade auch wieder für ein Buchprojekt damit beschäftigt. Und du kannst wirklich so viele Geschichten über diesen Verein erzählen, weil er einfach so eine bewegte Vergangenheit hat, weil es ihn einfach auch schon so lange gibt. Aber es ist eine unfassbare Bürde. Es baut Druck auf, es baut Begehrlichkeiten auf. Und das Publikum in Lautern ist halt so, es gibt Himmel noch jauchzend und zu Tode betrübt. Also es ist entweder schwarz oder weiß. Es ist Jubel, Trubel, Heiterkeit oder alle sind tief traurig. Also es ist einfach so, sobald die anfangen wieder einigermaßen Fußball zu spielen, dann träumen alle wieder. Und dieses ganze Umfeld, wer das Stadion gesehen hat, und wir haben auch, ihr habt auch darüber gesprochen, wie viele Fans auf die Auswärtsspiele kommen und so. Es ist natürlich von diesem Drumherum, von der Fanbase, vom Stadion und so, ist es Erstligalike. Ja, da müssen wir nicht drüber streiten. Das ist Fakt, auch von den Zuschauerzahlen her. Aber man muss auch sagen, dieses große Gebild der FCK, mit allem, was dranhängt, mit den Finanzen und so weiter und so fort, kommt aus den Drittliga-Jahren. Da hat man die Struktur komplett runtergefahren. Und quasi dieses Stadion hat noch existiert, aber alles drunter war halt eher Drittliganiveau. Es ist jetzt teilweise immer noch, weil man erst langsam diese Strukturen wieder aufbaut. Von daher langsam wieder aufbauen und dann, sage ich mal, ab nächstem Jahr vielleicht...
Nein, nein, das ist ja schon total falsch. Also, sorry, aber jetzt mal ein kurzer Reality-Check. Rohergebnis, erste FC Kaiserslautern, Saison 21-22. Das sind die letzten Zahlen, die wir von der DFL haben. Das, was man eingenommen hat, 19 Millionen Euro. 19 fucking Millionen Euro. Ich predige in der Bundesliga-Männer-Sendung immer, dass du als Aufsteiger irgendwie versuchen musst, 100 Mio zu reißen, dann kannst du in der Liga bleiben. Jetzt gucken wir uns mal an, was hatte denn Darmstadt 98, 26 Millionen? Klingt nicht, ist immer noch viel, viel weniger. Aber prozentual ein Riesenunterschied. Was hatte Heidenheim schon doppelt so viel? 39 Millionen. Was hat der VfL-Buch rum? Warte, ich habe es nur gerade rausgesucht. 63 Millionen Euro. Das sind andere Dimensionen. Natürlich kann ein Wunder geschehen, und du kannst mal aufsteigen. Aber es ist nicht wahrscheinlich, selbst wenn du es nachhaltig machen kannst, es ist nicht wahrscheinlich. Und dass Fans nicht so denken, das soll ja auch immer so sein. Ich würde als Fan auch nicht so denken wollen. Und als ich noch Fan war, habe ich auch nicht so gedacht. Das ist ja fürchterlich. Das ist ja schlecht für die Seele. Aber Verantwortungsträger dürfen doch dem nicht erliegen. Und die dürfen doch dann auch nicht einfach einen Trainer rauswerfen.
Nein, das Problem ist, oder eins der vielen Probleme ist, du hast zum Beispiel auch diese Situation, weil wir jetzt gerade auch beim Thema Finanzen sind, der FCK ist ja nur Mieter im eigenen Stadion. Und diese Geschichte wird dir halt immer weiterhin zum Verhängnis werden, weil es, und das sagt die Vereinführung auch, dass du dieses Ding nur dann wirtschaftlich betreiben kannst, eigentlich, wenn du in der ersten Liga spielst. Die sind jetzt mittlerweile dran, da auch einen neuen Pachtvertrag auszuhandeln, aber da gibt es, glaube ich, noch viel zu tun. Und deswegen ist es einfach so, das ist das, was ich meine, dieses Konstrukt ist jetzt das falsche Wort, der FCK ist alles andere als ein Konstrukt, aber die Struktur ist ungesund und deswegen ist man so ein bisschen verdammt dazu, erfolgreicher zu sein und aufzusteigen.
Ja, okay, das verstehe ich. Aber das heißt, ihr habt aktuell einen Heimsschnitt von rund 43.000 Zuschauern. Das würde jetzt nicht reichen, um die Miete zu bezahlen für diese Stade.
Das reicht dann mittlerweile schon, aber man muss sich das immer so vorstellen, das hören jetzt, glaube ich, auch einige Stadion-Romantiker nicht gerne, die den Betzenberg über alles lieben. Betzenberg ist ein tolles Stadion, das wird zwar das Stadion, keine Frage. Es ist aber sehr in die Jahre gekommen. Dieses Stadion, da muss sehr, sehr, sehr viel Geld reingesteckt werden, jedes Jahr, damit da der Laden läuft. Ich habe die Zeit jetzt nicht im Kopf, aber allein schon, wenn dieses Stadion auch nur aufgeschlossen wird, wie viele 10.000 Euro das kostet. Es ist immer noch ein tolles Stadion, aber es kostet einfach unglaublich viel Geld, dass es diesen Ist-Zustand erhalten kann. Wenn wir da jetzt einsteigen wollen, Thema Umsatz, Thema Finanzen in der ersten Liga, es ist jetzt auch schon so, dass die VIP-Tickets quasi auf Jahre hinweg mehr oder weniger vergriffen sind. Es gibt zu wenig VIP-Plätze, es gibt zu wenig logische Plätze. Da müsstest du irgendwie nochmal nachbessern in der ersten Liga. Da ist da sicherlich auch nochmal ein bisschen mehr gefragt. Da gibt es zwar auch noch Potenzial, aber es ist einfach so, das Ding kostet Geld und dementsprechend ist es dann einfach schwierig, das irgendwie wirtschaftlich zu betreiben. Aber ja, das, was du gesagt hast, da gebe ich dir auch recht. Und was da ja dazu kommt, du hast ein paar Kennzahlen jetzt genannt, aber diese Schere zwischen den Vereinen, die jetzt auch, sage ich mal, nicht erst zwei, drei, sondern vier, fünf, sechs, sieben, zehn Jahre plus Bundesliga spielen und dem FCK, der jetzt gerade aus Drittliga-Zeiten kommt und jetzt gerade mal das zweite Jahr Zweite Liga spielt, ist so unfassbar groß und die wird ja von Jahr zu Jahr größer. Selbst wenn du jetzt nicht mehr noch mal runtergehst in die Dritte Liga, sondern dich in der Zweiten Liga etablierst. Das ist ja, ich meine, guckt euch an, was mit den Aufsteigern passiert. Du hast auch den einen oder anderen Namen schon genannt. Die können, selbst wenn die dann teilweise den doppelten Umsatz haben als die Konkurrenz, also für die ist es genauso schwer. Guckt euch Darmstadt an, guckt euch Heidenheim an. Das ist ja so. Wenn du dann hochgehst, dann ist das oft halt einfach so ein Kurzausflug. Kevin nimmt auch schon die Kader.
Du musst dich ja quasi in der Zweiten Liga etablieren. Und da ist doch gerade Lautern gut dabei. Ihr habt es doch schon, einer von euch weiß gerade nicht mehr, wer es gesagt hat. Ihr habt ja schon gesagt, Braunschweig und Osnabrück. 8 Punkte und 7 Punkte. Genau, Kevin hat es gesagt. Das ist ja das große Pfund gerade für alle, für die es gerade darum geht, in dieser Liga zu bleiben. 10 Punkte Vorsprung hat der FCK. Und ich verstehe schon, dass einem da die Muffen gehen, wenn man dann so eine schlechte Serie hat und so weiter und so fort. Aber es ist doch alles noch gerade wunderbar. Und das Ziel muss es doch erst mal sein, jetzt 5 Jahre Zweite Liga zu spielen.
Ich muss sogar auch ganz provokant noch dazu sagen, nicht nur Braunschweig und Osnabrück. Ich schaue da auch ganz, ganz intensiv auf Schalke. Weil ja, es tut mir leid. Ich kenne auch viele Schalke-Fans sehr, sehr gut. Aber ich kann aus eigener Erfahrung sprechen, wie schnell man dann abrutscht. Oder abrutschen kann, diese Gefahr dann auch mal durchgereicht zu werden. Ich habe am Anfang der Saison auch gedacht, oh, die Hertha muss ich auch mal umschauen. Die haben sich jetzt mittlerweile stark gefangen, aber die haben auch, muss man sagen, ein Kader, der alles andere als abstiegshaufig ist. Ja, aber ich würde es mir auf jeden Fall wünschen, dass Schalke definitiv in der Liga bleibt, bzw. sich fängt und wieder weiter oben angreift. Aber es ist verdammt schwer, wenn du mal wirklich da unten drin steckst, da auch wieder rauszukommen. Der FCK hat es erlebt, dann geht es ruckzuck, und dann bist du auf einmal in dieser dritten Liga. Und da dann wieder rauszukommen, bock schwer.
Wir haben es auch erlebt damals.
Wie ist der Trainer damals, der die strömenden Wetter euch noch gerettet hat am 34. Spieltag im Fritz-Walter-Wetter? Wer war der Trainer noch mal, Sebastian?
Damals, 2008, meinst du? Gegen Köln?
Ja, genau.
Milan Zasic, meinst du Milan Zasic?
Ja, Milan Zasic, genau. Ich habe noch gedacht, es regelt. Fritz-Walter-Wetter. Ich habe das damals auf der Autobahn gehört, zwischen Augsburg und München.
Mir fällt bei Kaiserslautern immer nur Olaf Marsal an.
Olaf Nagenpflaster Marsal.
Ich kann mich da noch genau dran erinnern. Ich habe das im Radio gehört, natürlich. Der Kommentator hat die Frage gestellt, Herr Zasic, als es vorhin angefangen hat zu regnen, haben Sie da auch gedacht, Fritz-Walter-Wetter. Da dachte ich mir noch, das ist aber eine komische Frage. Und dann sagt Milan Zasic, da sagen Sie was, genau das. Ich habe gesagt, das ist unsere Hütte. Und ich dachte mir so, okay, geile Frage, muss ich mir merken.
Er war ja auch damals, hat er einige Schlagzeilen gemacht, als er die Mannschaft in die Kurve geschickt hat. Und sie hat sie quasi dazu gezwungen, sich auspfeifen zu lassen nach einer Niederlage. Ich weiß gar nicht mehr, gegen wen das war. Aber das war quasi mitten im Abstiegskampf. Und er hat die Mannschaft vor die Kurve zitiert. Die mussten sich da 5, 6 Minuten richtig beschimpfen lassen.
Es war nicht alles gut unter Ihnen.
Ich wollte sehen, dass Sie sehen diese Verzweiflung in die Auge. Also ich kann es nicht so gut nachmachen. Aber das war schon auch ein spezieller Typ. Aber ja, um darauf nochmal zurückzukommen, 2. Liga, ich persönlich finde ja auch rein von den Namen her, und das sage ich jetzt wirklich nicht, weil ich Reporter und Richterstatter über die 2. Liga bin, ich finde die 2. Liga viel geiler als die Bundesliga. Rein von den Namen her und von den Clubs her.
Es geht mir tatsächlich fast ähnlich so diese Saison. Es ist ganz extrem dieses Jahr, wie sehr mein Interesse sich ein bisschen stärker nochmals auf die 2. Liga verlagert hat.
Das ist schon krass. Außer das Einzige, was ich dieses Jahr spannend finde, ist, ich meine, ich will jetzt nicht zu sehr über die Bundesliga reden, aber was Leverkusen diese Saison auf dem Platz zaubert, ist schon ganz nett anzusehen. Aber ich gucke tatsächlich auch sehr wenig.
Die haben wirklich schön weit gegen uns gespielt im Pokal. Also da hast du richtig gesehen, ohne abdriften zu wollen, dass die wirklich einfach umschalten konnten. Also wir haben das 1-2 gemacht und haben sich gedacht, ach ja, jetzt müssen wir doch noch mal kurz ein paar Minuten Gas geben. Man ist 3-1 vier Minuten später. Dann haben sie wieder runtergefahren, haben wir das 2-3 gemacht. Das war dann abseits und dann war das Spiel vorbei. Und vorher, also das 1-0 von dem, wie heißt er, Boniface. Unfassbar. Unser Innenverteidiger klebt an ihm. Und der macht das Ding trotzdem so was von easy mit dem Inneres weg.
Ich finde, es lohnt sich allein schon wegen der Trainingsvideos, wenn man dann Xabi Alonso sieht, wie alt ist er mittlerweile. Keine Ahnung, immer noch die Bälle da zentimetergenau in der Mitte seiner Schützen gespielt.
Und wie sympathisch der auf der Pressekonferenz auch rüberkommt. Das sind in meinen romantischen Erinnerungen auch an früher diese weltmännischen Typen, die einem völlig unterlegenen Gegner immer noch was Gutes zusprechen können. Und wirklich sportsmännisch darumlaufen. Oder wie nennt man das jetzt? Ich weiß nicht, Max, sagt man noch sportsmännisch? Ich weiß nicht. Ein Gentleman, so würde man auch gesagt.
Böse Zungen könnten uns jetzt vorwerfen und behaupten, wir reden jetzt nur so gut über Leverkusen, weil keiner die im Pokal als Gegner haben will.
Ja, bitte nicht.
Ich mag das los, auch maximal Kacke.
Ihr wart ja auch in Freiburg, müsstet ja schon auswärts ran.
Da hatten wir ja zuerst ein Spiel in Berlin bei der Hertha, dann ging es nach Freiburg und dann nach Karlsruhe. Wir hatten also drei Auswärtsspiele in einer Woche. Das war toll. Und was für Distanzen. Wenn du da als Fan mitgereist bist komplett, hast du ein paar Tausend Kilometer drauf gehabt.
Wir warten jetzt allerdings auch seit rund fünf Jahren auf ein Heimspiel im Pokal. Das ist wirklich ein großes Thema in Düsseldorf. Wir hoffen auf ein Heimspiel und bitte nicht Stuttgart oder Freiburg.
Auf Freiburg fahren wir jetzt immer wieder gerne.
Lass mich noch ganz kurz, weil wir jetzt ein bisschen abgeschweift sind. Es ging ja eigentlich auch mal um den Trainer und so weiter. Ich möchte gerne eine Sache auf jeden Fall noch kurz loswerden, die einfach auffällig ist und die mir einfach wichtig ist, anzusprechen. Ich hatte ja angedeutet, dass ich der Meinung bin, dass Dimitrios Kamotsos wahrscheinlich nicht die 1A-Lösung war. Und so ist es halt bei vielen Fans auch angekommen. Und für viele Fans ist er halt nach wie vor auch nicht die Wunschbesetzung, sozusagen. Und es war sehr bedenklich zu sehen, was dann da erzählt und geschrieben wurde und behauptet wurde und gegrüllt wurde. Also eigentlich hat der arme Mann von Anfang an schon verloren gehabt, weil mehr oder weniger die Hälfte aller Leute ihn gar nicht haben wollten. Ich weiß nicht, wie oft das bei anderen Vereinen schon so war, wenn irgendwo ein neuer Trainer kam, dass da wirklich so eine große Antipathie herrschte. Hängt natürlich auch damit zusammen, dass viele immer noch Anhänger von Dirk Schuster waren und natürlich nicht damit einverstanden waren, dass er da entlassen wurde. Aber was da dann teilweise abgesondert wurde, auch in den einschlägigen Fonds und so weiter, das ist schon grenzwertig. Ich meine, ich verstehe, dass das Leute vielleicht enttäuscht sind, aber ich finde, das Mindeste, was ein Trainer verdient hat, ist, dass er zumindest die Chance bekommt, mal anzukommen und einfach mal zu zeigen, dass er vielleicht auch das Vertrauen der sportlichen Führung verdient hat. Wenn das dann nicht bringt, dann können ihn die Leute immer noch auspfeifen und rausrufen. Das ist so, ist das Geschäft halt. Aber was tut man seinem Verein und seiner Mannschaft für einen Gefallen, wenn man den Trainer von Anfang an so in Frage stellt? Also das ist einfach, ja, fand ich sehr, sehr bedenklich. Und von daher hat er jetzt natürlich, kann man sagen, direkt schon eine Antwort gegeben mit dem Sieg im Pokal. Jetzt warten wir mal ab. Ich habe auch gesagt, für mich eigentlich so schön das ist, im Pokal da auch weiterzukommen und vielleicht je nach Los, die Chance zu haben, dass es diese Saison auch mal echt relativ weit geht im Pokal. Das Kerngeschäft ist und bleibt die Liga. Also wenn ich, wenn, ich glaube, wenn die meisten Leute sich jetzt aussuchen könnten, wo der FCK seine Spiele gewinnt, dann würden sie auch die Liga nehmen. Und da stehen jetzt wirklich nochmal ein paar harte Spiele bevor. Jetzt kommen im Samstag Heimspiel gegen Hertha. Das wird alles andere als einfach. Die sind auch richtig gut drauf. Ich habe echt ein bisschen Angst vor Reze, muss ich sagen. Was der im Moment spielt.
Aber der wird viel rotieren, hat er schon gesagt.
Ja, aber den rotiert er bestimmt nicht raus. Und dann tatsächlich auch noch in Braunschweig, auch wenn die Tabelle es anders vermuten lässt, aber das musste er auch erstmal gewinnen. Und dann schauen wir mal, wie es nach der Winter- oder wie man dann zur Winterpause steht. Von daher, aber ja, wie gesagt, das mit Kramozis wollte ich einfach mal loswerden, weil das einfach...
Er kann nichts dafür und das ist sowieso... Also Hate Speech generell muss man sich sparen. Meine Güte, das war der längste 2. Liga-Kurzpass diese Saison. Gut, dass du gesagt hast, Sebastian, dass du raus musstest. Das haben wir ja ganz fantastisch...
Haben wir super geschafft...
.bekommen. Ich erspare euch jetzt die Quoten zum Spiel Nürnberg gegen Lautern. Die sprechen nämlich gegen stärkste 2. Liga aller Zeiten und so weiter. Das ist leider... Ich sehe das auch so, dass viele Vereine da einen Reiz haben, die mancher Erstligist nicht erfüllt. Quoten und auch Sponsoren und sonstige Ausgaben sprechen, aber leider klar gegen diese These. Das muss man wirklich sagen. Auf meinen Lesungen wird das häufiger gesagt von Leuten, die sagen, die 2. Liga ist doch viel besser, viel weniger langweilig als die 1. Liga. Ich habe ja irgendwie so 30 Lesungen gemacht. Jetzt habe ich bestimmt 8-10 Mal diese Frage. Dann habe ich irgendwann angefangen, zurückzufangen, sag mir mal die ersten 3 in der 2. Liga. Einmal wurde es beantwortet. Ansonsten wussten diejenigen, die gesagt haben, die 2. Liga ist viel geiler, als die 1. wussten es nicht. Konnten mir aber alles erzählen über Boniface, über Bayern und über Dortmund. Interzic hat keine Ahnung, weil er muss Chan nicht immer so zurückziehen in die Abwehr und so. Es ist leider in der Realität ein bisschen anders, als man es fühlt. Aber weil wir auch quasi noch diese Gefühle für diese Vereine haben, mit denen wir aufgewachsen sind. Kinder der 90er, 80er. Ja, so ist es eben. Den Reality-Check muss man dann auch bei sich selbst machen. Jetzt mache ich aber den Clock-Check und sage, das muss jetzt wirklich reichen, auch wenn ich mit euch allen drei noch ewig hätte weiterreden können. Ich habe auch ehrlich gesagt das Gefühl, ihr hättet mich gar nicht gebraucht, so wie das hier zwischendurch lief. Vielleicht gehe ich einfach pennen und ihr macht das hier alleine fertig. Also wirklich ganz, ganz herzlichen Dank. So ist das, wenn man mit Podcast-Profis aufnimmt. Das hat Riesenfreude gemacht. Herzlichen Dank an Kevin Bublitz. Ich werde den Padercast verlinken. Alle hören jetzt rein. Danke dir, Kevin, dass du mal wieder hier warst.
Danke auch für die Einladung. Immer wieder gerne.
Ja, und danke an Thorsten Wiese. Ein sensationelles Debüt. Ich wünschte, ich wäre bei meinem ersten Podcast-Auftritt, der leider auch noch zu finden ist, im Netz so souverän gewesen. Danke, Thorsten. Von gebrabbelrot-weiß wird natürlich auch verlinkt. Danke, dass du hier warst.
Ja, vielen lieben Dank für die Einladung, Max. Hat mich super gefreut.
Und wer noch mehrere Stunden von Sebastian Zobel hören möchte, der kann bei Nurder FCK reinhören und der kann im Rasenfunk reinhören. Ich werde noch mal die entsprechenden Tribüngespräche verlinken. Sebastian, danke dir, dass du, obwohl du so einen Titan-Terminplan morgen früh hast, darf man da überhaupt nur früh sagen, oder ist das noch nachts? Also gefühlt ist es noch nachts.
Ich werde von dir träumen heute Nacht, Max. In den wenigen Stunden, die mir noch bleiben.
Ja, meine Güte, es ist ein Drama. Also vielen Dank, dass du hier warst.
Ich danke dir, Max.
Ja, das kann ich nur so zurückgeben. Und euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, danke ich für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Der Rasenfunk ist paywall-werbungsponsorenfrei. rasenfunk.de/supportersclub. Und was kauft ihr leer? Genau, kiosk.rasenfunk.de kauft ihr leer. Kauf die Tasse für Mutti. Das ist das neue Hashtag zu dieser Sendung. Danke für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Empfehlt den Rasenfunk weiter. Bleibt uns gewogen, bleibt dran. Auf rasenfunk.de gibt es noch viele Sendungen mehr. Und bleibt vor allem gesund. Bis bald hier im Rasenfunk. Macht's gut. Das war der Rasenfunk.
Wir geben nun zurück in die angeschlossenen Funkhäuser.